[Music]
n
a n nah n nah
[Music]
nah
n
[Music]
yeah yeah might check might check what
is going on BR how we doing out there
how the levels is sounding make sure I'm
good what's going on what's going on do
a little roll call right quick we got
Lan Master what's going on let's do IOP
for to this one no question no question
Hite with the hustle appreciate you bro
appreciate you appreciate you want to
make sure I'm good om ABD what's going
on JM the OG oh hell IR lws you already
know Danny passion official popn no
doubt big z Mr seven digit Lieutenant
Hulk live Supremacy what's going on no
doubt appreciate y appreciate y Cur kid
drop no doubt what's going on yeah yeah
back for Dead all right see you in pack
brother it's going to be fun already
know yeah it's going we got a lady Mari
Atomic Mari pulling up in in a minute
too so just want to do a roll call have
some fun get into the game get into that
history get into these topics bring her
in right quick
the what's going on got that uh patriar
question lined up oh y'all on that no
PlayStation 6 yeah y'all on that front
line King stuff
again no doubt no doubt so we going to
get the legend in the realm soon Atomic
Mari the homie so it's going to be fun
and uh yeah see y'all in the
minute here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all to Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted to flipping the sample
and Mak it inflammable this is that this
is that Yoga Fire Flame that they can
saring up in the apartment they
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting and range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest of start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals on Twitter but I'm anal
love my city but I'm still by coal I
got's Don't Stop N that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoil feeling to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't here the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making V Tron with a
Ang cougar and I'm going places better
tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard to
sleep on Freddy krger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be a original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's sson up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting the
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got's Swit what
you do stop that was dope keep that keep
that going keep that going n Go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil feel to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boyal you ain't got to
say it I'm embarassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords's podcast right now
as we speaking of uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all missed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they it's saring up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got's
Swit that what you do stop that wase
keep keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoiled feeling to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am U
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they they it's Saron up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back we was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's switch that what you doing don't
stop that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil feel to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't got to say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertain until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
that they can Saron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on AIM check my vocals all on Twitter
but I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still by coal I got let's switch that
what you do stop that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel them to be
your dogs they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep I'm Fredy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not M go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want want to be on a
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let Swit
that what did you do Don't Stop N that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you can say it I'm very spoil to
be your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault try with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be handable
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is De Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's sson up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting the
rign you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on a check my vocals all on Twitter but
man anal love my city but I'm still by
Co I got let's
[Music]
switch keep that going keep that going
go ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil feel them to be your dog
they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault Tron with a gang of cougars
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if if you would not mind go
ahead and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to mess up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah be eating
these but that's all a part of me being
accountable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all to Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted the flip and the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's sing up in the apartment they call
a department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest of start regardless back
when you was messaging people people a
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still by
coal I got let's Swit what did you do
Don't Stop N that was dope keep keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you can say that
I'm very spoiled feeling to be your dog
they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't here the boy you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making vultron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber because it's pretty hard to sleep
on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that again
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing every
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being a accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be hanni
they be like why use a video gang just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still byal I got let's
switch that you stop that was do keep
keep that keep that going keep that
going go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil them to be your
dogs they ain't very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougar and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y' messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all Dramatical I know it's
random but I addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame that
they can saring up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting the
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest of started
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a got check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's Swit
that what you do stop n that was dope
keep that keep that keep that going keep
that going n Go ahead look I guess you
could say that I'm very spoil them to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making V Tron with a
gang of cougers and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the
[Music]
show all this PR
call loud and clear a proclamation of
invitation turn not on
me I cry the Praises of the life
[Music]
the River St lawence with
the I'mma just chill and watch them and
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young [__]
but then that would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cuz if you don't
give her that option you going to be
single player like Sovereign you going
to get tossed in the bushes by King
David royalty and not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental was a avatar
to a knee Bender I got to be me I know
it's my destiny work too who cares if
you fly if you still a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really be
steo you like to collect stuff and
that's cool but I got bad news even if
you really was that dude King still be
the king of the statues just a juvenile
I've been cursed with a curse to be
Musical and if you hate it we'll meet in
The Crucible other than that is cool and
it's beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cuz you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's Day
if you got work on a Sunday a suitable
cuz you can listen to this in your
cubicle on a L's
[Music]
day over switching over let's do a
secondary mic check lady Mari can we uh
hear you really quickly check Jack 1 2 3
4 five oh she got B she's
ready I know how to count what can I say
she's ready I love it I love it no doubt
real quick S one more time and you see
how we
doing ah there we go oh there we go you
know his fan base he's trying to tap
into today yes yes yes yes new year new
man new year
new I ha I hate that
phrase all that's all the new dudes in
the gym or what it is right
likeu first day I I quit yeah new new
day new day new year new s that's the
dude they they having up the gym I can't
get on the
machine ad what's up Mike check going on
can you guys hear me f yeah perfect oh
yes sir what out what out how you doing
how you doing all right let's get it
here ye here ye and we are live welcome
to the iron Lords podcast LLC and also
live on Lords of gaming.net oh no what
happened oh no nothing don't worry about
me don't oh know me as you just scared
that sorry sorry going through the intro
somebody go oh no I I saw something on
my screen don't worry about
me scared me like I thought I was like
yo we ain't got no no internet what's
happening and also live on Lords and
gaming.net episode number 336 and it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the round table on the Lord's day and
today I'm very excited about our special
guest and we've got the Xbox developer
direct Halo TV series season two
Y and Suicide Squad Alpha to discuss so
we go to get right into it I want to
introduce a lady who is not only a
multifaceted Talent within the
entertainment industry but always
demonstrates a pure passion for gaming
acting and hosting with her infectious
personality
introducing the co-owner of space
station G gaming the legendary augg and
smos games in addition to the host of
the atomic Mari YouTube channel the lady
of space expiration and Esports who
Still Remains the most legit ballarina
in Survivor Castaway
history live from Las Vegas and kind
enough to make her debut into the realm
of the Lords my girl lady Mari Takahashi
AKA a atomic Mari how we doing sis yo
hello Lords thank you golly hey I will
pay I will pay your $10
show I respect
that give you a good intro give you 10
bucks you do it that's that's what the
patreon here
respectfully thank you it's it's it's
lovely to be here um hello Chad how's it
going thank you for having me um yeah
I'm excited nice guys long overdue you
are a lady in your realm and what you do
with all how busy you've been have you
got a chance to play any games recently
oh that's a good question man because I
because I say this is for market
research I have to do
this it's a it's a nice tag Li that I
get to say but you know like lately I
feel like I've come into like more of
the mindset that I'm going to play stuff
that I want and that I like and without
it being like you know I got to do it
because I got to be able to speak on it
so it's a it's a nice balance I'm
striking it I'm fighting what that
balances no I respect that I've been
saying way I think I had this
conversation with uh Mr M plays who I do
find Duke with and it's the what what
happens is when it when it's was too
much reviews and stuff like that it
becomes homework and sometimes you just
want to play what you want to play and I
think it's healthy to do that so I
definitely agree that resonates no
question no question I mean it's a weird
time where you know
like we get in our head like oh do what
you love love what you do I don't know
we saw one too many like Facebook posts
like that right and so we're like what
do I like to do I like to play video
games all right I'll make it into my
work because then I'll love my work but
then you're totally right once it stops
being a passion then it's like what what
do we what did we just do to ourselves
so yeah keeping some games sacred has
been my key the my my favorite games I
will never play publicly yes yeah no
fair enough fair enough that's that's a
good concept yeah I never thought about
that yes salute to the lazy otaco he's
like Lady B can I get the link to the
hoodie it looks fire where can we get
the link damn they want the merch
already already with the merch oh my
goodness well let me show you this is
the uh the the hockey jersey from space
station gaming you shop. space.com shout
out to space station.com very iron Lord
friendly very black and gold we we
approve
yeah cuz those were in sof those were in
um Halo infinite I didn't know who space
station G was at the beginning and I was
like wait a minute D the one cuz you
know everybody's your sparting is kind
of Dusty and ashy mine mine in
particular you that's you do you know
that you he don't do no
microtransactions that dude right so
then I S I said yo that space station
joint look clean with the black and the
gold o yeah yeah yeah so I'm that's the
first ones you get yeah I bought that
they got that $10 to the design team oh
thank you golly I mean that's that's uh
that's definitely that warms my heart
appreciate it not that I can take credit
I'm just like I get to be a part of the
thing and very much how it feels no
doubt respectfully and you already know
we got the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords of the realm here at the
round table my co-host with the coost my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conquerer lord of the
spin clap and the H oh my
god of the young wolf
B it Lloyd addict of the addict show
back to back how we doing sir doing
pretty good uh playing that Prince of
paria
game The Game's actually really good
like it's one of the few of those you
know Sid scrolling type of Adventures
like that ory I do feel like ory feels
better because I I I feel too floaty as
the character in Prince of Persia but
okay like the story is told like really
really well like it actually makes me
interested in these characters like
that's what's up yes get a lot of good
reviews 60 frames everywhere I mean
develop on the switch first oh there you
go here we go no but they did they did
oh okay okay I thought he' be no no no
it's back to that whole thing of like
when you develop for the least common
denominator everything everything else
benefits from it right because you have
to you have to develop to the metal
right everything else is easier fair
enough so just prince pers C see he
thought he thought it was K I thought I
thought you a do I a't going I
wasn't you want to see the darts thrown
you want to look at our preview coverage
from last year from P West they were
darts thrown there yeah yeah or maybe
not it's in patrion though you want to
see it yeah you can see that in special
shout out thank you
yub for your your time absolutely yeah
I've been Hal infinite too like a lot of
it no doubt I've been playing that Halo
3 playlist
yeah fire for everybody telling me I
gotta get back some the best maps ever
made on
Halo that's what's up no doubt and of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sofus the Lord of crowns and
Messiah I don't like that mumbling at
the last part I I I said what I was
contraction supposed
to I can't tell so I don't know if you
actually said it or not Messiah and Lord
patreon of the iron pck PC Master Rises
own la and S how we doing sir I am good
I'm good glad to be back in full force
last week I had to dip out uh I went to
see Sweeney Todd on Broadway with my
sister it was very very good I've never
seen Sweeney Todd in person I've seen
like video of it whatever but it it's
it's very good show it's uh some people
go into it not knowing what it is and
they think it's like you it's it's it's
it's Broadway it's fluff or whatever but
the story is very dark right very Grim
it was there was an elder yeah they're
eating people right sorry
spoilers they're eating people in meat
pies yeah so um show about cannibalism
love fantastic and they so the guy it
was an elder elderly guy behind me and
my sister looks back and like so he he
in the middle of the show he gasps he's
like no I'm out of here he gets up he
walks out and my sister goes to the
bathroom during intermission she's like
he's sitting on a couch over there so
and he however much he paid for these
tickets he didn't care he's like I'm not
watching this and it it's not even I
mean again everything it's it's it's
implied right so you see blood and stuff
like that but it's it's nothing crazy
but but it was a good time he thought he
was going in for Wicked right he thought
he was going in for some real you know
like some real like Bob fossy dancer
something he's like eating bodies is
where I is where I officially cross draw
the
line it was definitely fun um gaming
what have I done this past week um so I
I went into Spider-Man 2 to clean up
some side quests and I did that um I
again the side quest stuff sets up the
next game or the the intertial that
we're not supposed to know about right
right kind of sets up for that stuff um
still I I enjoy the momentto moment
gameplay of that of of that game the
movement is great um both characters are
are great in terms of you know traversal
and gameplay um but I don't know that
I'm a platinum it I'm kind of I'm done
plat I looked I look been like two weeks
of him coming on here like I just not
feeling Spider-Man too
I coming back to it though yeah I come
back to it cuz I'm like I'm I'm close
enough that I could do it I don't know
that I want to do
it yeah so what I actually went back to
cuz again my my plays5 backlog um I went
back to Horizon I'm like you know what
let me let me let me try to finish
forbidden West
right what the same thing it's like
forbidden West technically up and down
it's an amazing game like everything
about that game technically the game is
beautiful it plays beautifully I just
aloy is
so lacking boring yeah she she lacks she
lacks in Charisma right and and and but
she's super heroic and it just and all
the characters around her are like are
like you know like wet socks too like
they're like they say everything with a
super like seriousness they in a whole
lot of like just the jokey joke moments
in in the game so it's just like I don't
know it
just it's it's enough that I'm I want to
see the story through so I'm going to
see the main story I'm going to go
through it um just like I did with the
first one but the rest of it I'm done
I'm done with
that but when you finish it then you'll
be caught up to everything that came out
last year oh my God here he go and then
like adex said uh shout out to ubisol
for the code for Prince of persa the
Lost Crown um I'm a Metroid Vania Stan I
love Metroid vanas going you know again
all the way back for for many many years
you know Super Metroid and and obviously
Symphony of the Night and things like
that um but this is this is good it's
very very oh man it's good it's good uh
the combat again the you change elements
of Metroid vas over the years right like
you look at a Symphony of the Night the
combat isn't as pronounced you know
alukard is super powerful and here it's
all about parrying and I guess later on
I'm not that far in but you're going to
get you know more different moves and
traversal moves and Combos and things of
that nature but the Cinematic nature of
this game like adct said is very cool
the bosses are cool humongous bosses
sometimes um do a lot with backdrops in
it like a lot with backdrops exactly the
backdrops are beautiful um so I'm
excited I played about 3 or 4 hours and
for me you know how I play games so I
spent most of that time trying to play
the game yeah oh on the Rock on the AL
on the Rock lady Mari knows about that
that Al I've seen I know I saw that
video yes the rock is is a special piece
of Kit man I'm big fan and I was sitting
in bed last night playing it for like
four or five hours um love it love it
and it runs beautifully so I'm excited
to to talk more about it next week no
doubt and of course we we have the
incredible Hoke of this aka the EXs
gamer o the prophet of Xbox Swami King
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
Undisputed leader of the Xbox Frontline
movement ooh beloved Lord King how we
doing sir I'm doing super fantastic the
the whole Voltron Force is here this is
going to be a great show um uh like
Sovereign I've been playing um what you
playing the the the Prince of Persia oh
you know s remember the first time we
got Prince of persan we was playing it
on the PC and the first time we saw the
rotoscope uh like movements it blew us
away it really did it really did you go
back to it it's it's really hard to go
back to you can't do it you can't do it
but they had so much luck with this
franchise this character because it went
away for a minute then we had got Sans
of time and Sans of time was incredible
right and then we didn't think that they
can strike gold again and somebody went
to the formula and said what do we
really perceive this game to be yes and
it took me back to the first time that I
put my Metroid cartridge inside my
Nintendo oh classic and I was like yo
it's got that feeling now I had to take
away my bias that I have for Ubisoft
about the whole thing that went down and
I did have a linger in effect with it
because I was talking to somebody in my
DMs about it and I said I had to remove
myself from it to actually grade the
game on its own merits and that would
transpired the game is really good oh
it's really good it was good enough to
pull me away from fortnite oh you know
it's good know how he do with the
fortnite yeah yeah yeah so oh shout out
to everybody that got the invisible
skins it's up it got back in the store I
had my money saved my vbucks was there
soon as I saw it I was like yo I felt
like a little school girl I was like
soon as I saw it I and I immediately put
on new clothes immedi put ONN man what
is it so they just invisible what's
going on well inin you saw the show
Invincible oh Invincible Oh I thought
you said there was invisible I like I
wish I was like how is everybody seeing
each other in the map I wish they would
make some kids get this invisible skin
invisible skin I feel like a hustle how
much is it $ $100 you know how you know
how many people would pay for that just
to troll
people yeah like that would be a troll I
got the new invisible skin you don't
like it you don't like it but too bad
I'm using it so explain that if y'all
want to go see adct and I I feel
betrayed I got I got to bring this to my
we got a situation we got a situation
what's going on I feel betrayed because
me and my man was in the trenches this
has this has to do with
you this was we was playing game of the
yeah quote unquote whatever B gate three
Bal is gate all right we got to these
goblins and AD and I adct and I yes yes
suffered I went to bed that night hating
Green Goblins I was mad and I was
plotting their destruction and I was
saying they must
die addict calls me the next morning and
says in roundabout conversation matter
really flippantly matter of fact really
just like it didn't matter yeah me and
Cog passed that
partc excuse me excuse me the goblin the
goblins and the girl yeah yeah we know
we we barely beat it by this I wanted to
hang up the phone on him so
bad disrespectful it's absolutely the
worst thing like come on we me and you
have our Saint like what the hell is
going on that's still that's still
revenge for that stride of thing you did
back nothing could stop him beating my
stream you act like we still don't have
the same
you act like me and jumped on our safe
point and beat the go you already
experienced Victory with someone else
King King what you cheated on me bro
cheated King what happens if I tell you
I've already beat that before I beat it
[Music]
with makes it worse he lose what is he
what
is I can't use the words right now for
you cuz we have a lady present but sir
sir where she said sir you are the type
of man you are not a One Gamer guy you
are gaming streets you found out you was
for the for the
street so so so Co this is what he
wanted me to do when you like yo you got
come jump on you help me with these
Goblin N I can't ick down lock in you
was locked I would have said that if
somebody would say hey man let's go beat
these goblins I'd be like no man I'm my
B I got to beat that okay
you know would have been you know what
would have been really bad if I got on
it I'm like PA come and help me beat
this these people and be be M and King
save and then King's like why'd you do
that why I didn't think we was doing it
with you oh my God you know what let's
move on that's all I've been playing I
thought I was going to go back to some
stuff on my PlayStation it is still
sitting there looking at me weird but I
will get back to it I want to get back
to the Final Fantasy 16 I really do I
have a anchoring for that no doubt shout
out and of course we have the gaming dig
himself the Shinobi L Cognito spread
that real rub I not telling what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to defining Duke Mr manty
plays we talking about Xbox exclusives
and locations potentially we shout out
to the last wordon T gu Travis we had on
um all time bana super dope doctor at St
jud's hospital and um she deals with
sick and cell as well as um dope
streamer in the destiny community and uh
s she grew up in them um them 360
lobbies bro remember them 360 360 Call
of Duty lobbies oh she's tough as
Nails she was telling me made a man out
of you yeah they hear the first female
voice and
you when you play with your friends and
then you hear the first female voice and
everybody switch up on you everybody
switch up everybody yeah it's one of two
things it's either it's either like
rampant misogyny or it's like trying to
be smooth yeah yeah the dude you got
that one dude CES whole toll and then
try to be smooth oh so let me let me
help you with your load out and you know
and you know the guys that automatically
friend request the immediate friend
request pop up in her
background Mario go down like that back
in day it didn't go down like that
that's why I always played with friends
cuz that don't get in trouble yeah
that's why I always play with people
that I
know it's so true it's either one of
those two dudes the extra misy or or or
extra smooth
dude but shout out to ban yeah she did
her thing go catch that up on ION
channel with the last word she was super
dope as far as games um yeah playing
that infinite wealth demo from like a
dragon giden so um like I said finish
guiding so still playing the demo
getting ready for my Ichiban you know
what I'm saying you got to get ready for
the new newe that's coming soon in
Hawaii obviously Boulders gate with with
adct yo I ain't going to front though
King that Goblin section is the wildest
section it like I it it's so difficult
it made me question my decision maybe I
should his
face I'm I'm just really disgusted to be
honest with you I'm move on I'm move on
for the Goblins I'm move on for the
goblin no I mean I understand how
frustrating it is but imagine going to
sleep like that and you're waking up in
the morning your boy tell you yeah we
did that we did that already now it's w
crazy difficult crazy trust me said we
did that but I already did it way before
and he did that's some truthful that's
that's truth that hurts you know what I
don't I don't like about long before I
know who you were in Boulder's
Gat I you know what I don't like about
adct and I gotta tell you it's like he's
like Jamie they will beat the G they
will have it all wrapped up and then and
then they will play it with you and act
like they don't know what's going on but
then but they let it slip oh maybe you
might want to hit that lever over there
oh Al in would would would you prefer me
just to spoil everything I know where
this is King go over here let's do
this it's better than the opposite is
your blues cluing at oh
I being super extra FR fire around can
someone point to it I wonder what's
going to happen
next don't be that
dude no doubt and doing that and then
king um Call of Duty Modern Warfare
three
campaign look I got to be real with Y
now all right let me put a caveat Cog
has not played a car campaign since like
Black Ops 3 I'm not played car campaign
in a minute so I heard all the discourse
about it yo it's the worst campaign is
this that and the third so I finally got
to it through the break and stuff and
I'm like I'm sitting there I'm like yo
this is dope this is mad fun did you
beat that part I was talking to you
about yes I beat the whole whole game
the whole game so so you saw when the
gas came in yeah was when the gas came
in you got to keep rising to the top to
try to avoid the joint now I get it some
people might not like the open world
missions but I I to me it's player
choice it's like you could go wherever
you want to attack it from how you want
to me it's like so it's like remember
remember that show
24 yeah and it like you know like it's
like the over beep beep like it's just
the overthe toop action set pieces crazy
drama wild villain marov who I thought
was dope and they had the old yeah they
had the old people from um Call of Duty
games what it and all the stuff the
variety of missions they got um even the
opening when you you you storm the Gage
that's in the island like alcatra fire I
thought the joint they had a joint I the
chick is ruthless she ruthless super
dope they had a biome in the snow where
the the field of vision is blurry and
and that they had a they had a Miss
there's two missions that stood out to
me specifically there's one where you in
um Europe and it's like a you know like
one of them premier league stadiums or
whatever
and all the fans that is getting
attacked like they're undercover police
posing as police killing civilians right
so then you see the civilians running
towards you and the whole Miss it's it's
a lot of NPCs you cannot shoot them when
the mission is over y right so you got
that and then another one that stood out
and then it was a little controversial
but I like the way they did it was like
um they had the I guess like the um
Muslim faction or whatever and they
tried to frame them for airport like a a
plane bomb and Joint I was like yo they
going there like this this game is crazy
like it it was just a lot of different
set pieces and again for people who may
say yo that's just reuse assets if you
like that play this this is better but
I'm not going to say that game was a
four like reviewed as the like that game
to me is no less than a seven like but
that's just me if they were never picked
up by Microsoft it would have been an
eight oh there you and you know Xbox tax
is real and we are outside I'm just
saying I enjoy the game but anyway
enough about all that so let's get to
get a couple super chats before we start
yeah we'll get a couple super chats so
we don't have rules of engagement today
says lady Mari will be rocking with us
okay great fantastic all right let's
start off with hindsight with hustle
member for 24 months Lord bronze uh how
many mm in your chain kog I'm looking to
purchase a Miami Cuban soon oh you try
to
get Kuba no doubt Cuban links the Cuban
Link and we got Craig put the crust of
the chat for Craig hooligan gifting one
membership thank you
[Music]
salate and we got loget finest Robert
kellet $10 Super Chat bless day Lords I
want to honor my 25-year-old cat Smokey
he was my best friend and always was
with me when listening to you guys
treasure our pets and treat them like
family thank you
Lorden to you man sorry for your loss
man salute and we got Craig hooligan
once again member for 16 18 months Lord
bronze I finally started Spider-Man 2 my
costume is clipping characters are
running into into and through walls and
it definitely feels clunkier Than
Miles yeah kind it was kind of rough
they had to pay the bills bro stop
playing let's go what else we
got oh are your friends are here that's
why his voice changed up that's but his
friends are here in the Super Chat let's
talk about it do doct Strange Love $5
super chat Sav I can give you my meat
pie with another pie of cream on the
side oh my God talking about Broadway
Broadway you go hey hey hey
hey back to
you Mrs love meat
ties once again thank you for your to be
fair you you gave them that one on a
silver
platter I'm talking super pause pause I
did not give them any meat on any
plet I didn't say that I you see you
just put extra spice on it they going to
do another Super Chat now this is your
fault shout out to Dr Str love shout out
to Dr Str
love stick is coming yeah you know it's
pause yeah we got Hollywood rules $5
Mari we are children here just so you
know
yeah in there no doubt no doubt yeah we
got Hollywood rules $5 Super Chat happy
Sunday to my NYC in West Virginia cousin
sitting Upstate and in upstate n y with
no power right now wind issues but I got
my IOP boys to get me through shout out
to you SL sorry about the going that
yeah that's the worst yeah no power if
you playing The Rock on with with no
power battery he done he only got like
an hour
hour bring it yeah bring it down bring
it down to like 10 watts just play C
Stars see stars bring your brightness
down do what I do yeah no AAA gaming for
you for right now no exactly let's put
the crest in the chat for the newest
member of the realm Lord bronze big Z
out
salute then we got Hollywood rules $2
Super Chat invisible skins
pause y'all are extra manra today extra
we got jar iny $5 Super Chat thanks for
the entertainment huge love thank you
sir appreciate salute Iceland in the
building I got your message brother
again sending love over there to the
whole country we see what's going on
with the volcano did you get the Steve
Hodge one Steve Hodge it was right
before the oh okay hod Steve hod with
the $10 Super Chat on lunch so I had to
pop in after seeing the last of a show
Halo season 3 is going to Recon with uh
with Chief walking up at the start of
Halo uh combat Edition saying man that
was a weird dream than the
show wow Ron R they no they told you
what they going to do right from the
J face we going to talk about it we
going to talk about it what else we got
then we have Hollywood rules once again
$2 Super Chat Cod campaign is a blend of
24 Homeland and Jack Ryan facts they got
my man from um 242 agent pierce the one
he was loyal to Jack B and The Crew He
in he in Call of Duty it's lit hashtag
it was dope I like it me too I love it
yep continue then we got let's put the
crest in the chat for Lord Bron Matt
welcome to the round M than so much
salute then we have Lee Fitness $5 for
chat then Mari what are your thoughts on
Smite 2 thanks for the content Lords
thank you oh my God I'm okay so uh uh
thank you for the question Lee um I was
a huge Smite fiend would go to Smite
World Championships year after year it's
the reason why I am associated with with
space station in the first place when I
was at swc in I want to say maybe 17 or
so uh I saw space station there and the
the guy who created it uh Sean and I we
knew each other I'm like John what are
you doing here and he's like I got a
team and I'm like I'm an instant fan
nice and so I've got I've got a lot of
roots in Smite and dropped off
completely when I stopped working in a
office full of friends and so it was it
was a thing that we would always do
during lunch and whatnot so um I'm very
excited to come back to Smite too um
kind of I don't know refreshed and
having had a long long break that's
what's up that's what's up they still
Smite Smite was fun yeah Smite the
community is insane I know that was your
first experience they like still they
still want you to turn up a little bit
like so turn up your bik just a little
bit they like we want to hear Lady Mar
even
louder I'm like all right C probably in
the zoom settings yeah I showed them
before they they still B like we want to
hit talks too much sh all right we got
you we got you don't you worry about it
apprciate no doubt no
doubt Dr Strange Love once again $2
Super Chat s don't worry I'll give you
my meat on the platter that's great
wow you got to keep you got to keep it
together brother you got to keep it
together thank you thank you for your
support appreciate that
shakery Sher yo
continue There we got the homie harde
shiny $2 Super Chat salute Lords welcome
to the realm Mari oh thank you salute we
all caught up yeah we are caught up all
right let's get it let's get into it now
we got caught up with everything and
these intros five
hours
get and with the Lords and FL we got to
shift our Focus back to Lady Mari her
video I can't believe we did the intro
in 33 minutes I know that's actually a
record for us that's actually a record
her video game system history she like
what's going on her journey as a
professional ballerina and of course
would led her to content creation and
all the things dope things we know off
for smash a being the co-owner of space
station gaming and many cool
opportunities in the entertainment space
so Lady Bar let's start from the
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming um my dad is an engineer
he's an electrical engineer so I
remember we had uh for sure Atari in the
house we had a familyc in the house wait
wait I had oh we we took that from the
mother we took that from I'm pretty sure
he brought it back from from his uh
business trip because yeah and it's one
of these things when you're a kid it
just arrives in your house and it's like
oh this is a toy that I'm going to play
with because it's here you don't really
question where it comes from um yep uh
you know and and like with the the
Atari years later I found out out about
you know the the infamous
ET but for years I stole that cartridge
from my older brother because I loved ET
never played it never stuck it into the
console I just saw ET on the cover and
I'm like oh this is
mine K loves
ET oh yeah the 2600 version I leave
below he don't want that story on
I actually beat that
game KATU and I yeah we kind of figured
it out um it's you know you phone home
and then you go home and that's it and
that's the movie right simple mov just
avoid the pit that's it just avoid the
pit avoid the uh the FBI agents chasing
you you know be funny if like half the
game was phing home the other half was
an alien invasion yeah complete
different continue Mar so you had that
but but I think the first console not I
think I know the first console that felt
like it was mine was the Genesis
um I had the Genesis my neighbor had uh
an SNES and you know it was the it was
the '90s conso war yeah and I fully
bought into it I'm like oh you're a
square with your little
Nintendo is does what
Nintendo oh she's a Sega girl l
commercials you know it's the thing
where like my dad was a ners fan and I
was a Raiders fan because of just y beef
it on the bank y beef they were let's go
you put the face paint on oh my God I I
saw the men with the face paint on and I
was like hey that's my team my my
father's like absolutely not I'm
like I like him I go yeah silver blacks
kind of fire can't can't front on the
color scave can't front on it you know
what I'm saying that's what's up okay
now they're now they're Vegas so yeah oh
yeah where you at that's right it's full
circle for you now I think about that
they came home to you salute so let me
just back up again with the with the
Genesis so it's like any standouts games
on the Genesis area that kind of lured
you to the console I you know it's one
of those chicken or egg sort of
situations I was so young that I don't
know which came first of like like did
did the games just arrive or did I pick
them out all I know is that I loved um
Road r
I love Road Rash I love Mortal Kombat of
course um with the
blood i road rash basically you're on
motorcycles and you just chain whip
people you're trying to race awesome and
that little hint of chaos while you're
trying to do something um you know very
straightforward and deliberate but while
also doing this you got the bat you got
the chair and you knocking them off it's
like you be a violet to get the first
play I Love It and you had to the cops
in that game too I believe yeah yeah
yeah you I think there were um so yeah
those are kind of the standouts and then
you know there's a there's memories of
tail spin in there
um yeah memories of DK country and you
know that's that's me going back and
forth between the Snus and and being at
home yeah all right so after the Super
Nintendo then we we continued on you
remember what with the next the
progession was was stay in console PC or
what you remember what was next after
the the Gen that was that was a that was
considered like a golden era yeah yeah
definitely into the CD ROM era um yeah
Sega CD or Turbo Graphics C or any one
of those just skip Sega CD yeah I think
it was into PlayStation by then oh yeah
and then I was just in the PlayStation
era which I was you know there I was
kind of off and on um I know I really
detracted from the final fantasy series
which I think is going to be you know
that's that's controversial it's totally
controversial yeah I I was having an
identity crisis where I'm like well I
don't want to like the things that my
brother
likes and he loved he loved it and so
I'm like not for me
um yeah so it gets a little blurry
around there but uh yeah I I guess I
just never really stopped until I sold
my Xbox 360 wow um and then I was like
can't man like I I just can't focus on
anything I'm letting it go oh this was
this was you putting self check on
yourself cuz you doing too much gaming
like why you had to 360 go I'm just
curious I think it it it sort of it got
caught up to me where I was just like I
don't think that this is a good way for
me cuz I gaming was never supposed to be
the Avenue I'm not supposed to be
I feel like I'm in a weird side
quest that became the main story line
and I should not be sitting here um but
it is where I am Mar started Mari
started scym what everywhere but White
Run where are you supposed to be let's
get it oh I am supposed to be working at
my mother's ballet studio that she
basically you know created from nothing
in order to pass down to me um I started
ballet when I was 2 and a half years old
and started working on contract touring
at 3 years old wow until I was 11 years
old and I went professional at 17 so
like I should be dancing I should be a
ballerina how how did you have time to
game at all yeah I think gaming
was before I really knew it it was my
way of rebellion okay I love this I love
the edge I like this
addict I'm play these games I do Escape
my mom is a valerina and it's the thing
that you know like like it's my destiny
I have to do it and so I had no way of
wavering from it it was literally do
ballet or get out of the house and like
that I see I see I saw um a documentary
on how ruling it is on the body you know
the feet and stuff like that and
especially as a young child you know
they would you would did they bind your
feet because you had to stand on your
toes and are you asking if my feet look
like a meat
pie kind of around about way you know it
was
um I mean it's they're not pretty for
sure but you don't have to bind them
because the shoe that you have to stick
your feet in is like it's like a rock
climbing shoe it is much much smaller
than what a normal foot should be able
to be crammed into but it is the utility
piece that allows you to put your entire
body weight onto I don't know maybe a
couple square inches and balance on your
toe don't don't people like sew it to to
to their foot or something like like sew
the actual material together I love that
that is a thought process that's badass
and awful yeah oh my God no you don't
you don't sew it to your skin but you
sew no I me you SE the material together
like sew it literally together yeah you
do for
performances um so that the ribbons
don't fall out how do you know that ad I
saw it on Tik Tok Tik Tok Tik Tok shout
Tik Tok ballet Tik Tok you know I don't
know what it was but I was scrolled and
oh you got C out it popped up and I'm
like what they
doing Bella says hello that's amazing I
love it shout out to Bella Bella B says
hello yeah she wanted to be all extra
and I'm like how the hell did you get
down here salute to Bella continue on so
again you got this Dynamic where again
you know family business Mom this is
what you what you're supposed to be
doing and then gaming is the escape to
kind of get away from that so like how
did we get to that point where ballerina
actually stopped didn't that that seems
to be like a a sticking point in the
family I would assume you correct that
was a difficult conversation that yeah
how did that go it was a gradual
conversation and you know I I think the
The Tipping Point was smos right like I
when I started with smos it was 2010
before YouTube was really seen as a
career it was still seen as the
strange um it was still seen as like the
like a fringe thing you know if you told
somebody the number of times I'm like
yeah I make YouTube videos they're like
what is that I'm like well I make videos
with myself on it and they're like
oh so let me let me back up just a
smidge because okay I I I get that it's
gradual but like how did the YouTube
consecration how did what was the origin
story of how did you get into spot were
you creating content on your own first
and then she's laughing she got this
story she made a p this story so it's
like how did the smash Discovery
happened this is the part where I'm like
this is why I know I'm not supposed to
be sitting here doing this let's go
let's go let's go um so when when I was
working full-time as a ballerina my
contract ends um in the summer so I have
a couple of months off in the summer
where I'm not getting paid so I take any
job ever like I would go to birthday
parties dressed up as as as a ballerina
I was a magician's assistant which I'll
never
freaking for my next trick I'm sorry for
all the magicians in the in the chat but
I can't with magicians I
have but it's from personal experience
I'm very annoyed by it okay so I would
take any job ever I'm scaming around
Craigslist and all these things and
there's a Craigslist for basically
entertainers and it's um it's it's you
know a forum and a board just the same
and so one day I'm on it and there I see
a posting that says hey we'll pay 50
bucks for somebody who knows how to
speak Japanese for an online video and I
was like 50 bucks all right that's great
all right all right and it's in
Sacramento I live in San Francisco um
and so I drive up and it happens to be a
smos shoot oh I don't know who smos is
you don't even know what this is go okay
no I don't know who they are I don't
watch their videos and we're talking
2010 so this is far before YouTube was
seen as like the premier place to go to
for entertainment um this is before
YouTube even knew what they were going
to
do early days you YouTube saw these guys
and they're like I don't know people
keep watching their stuff mind you in
2010 these guys smile
Ian and Anthony had 10 million
subscribers on their main channel oh
they were 10 Milli back then okay yeah
so I think they were either first second
or third most
subscribed and um so I do this video
with them and it is the Pokemon theme
song Revenge song
so these guys get famous originally for
lipsyncing to Pokemon and they get a
they get uh DMC stried by Nintendo oh
Nintendo they said you're not going to
be spitting those bars imagine yes
Nintendo not trying to hear none of that
they talk nintend not play they do not
they do not and I have I have thoughts
on why they don't and anyway
um either way they rip it off the
internet years later they're big enough
to to literally say like I think they
say the actual words but they're like Fu
Nintendo in it right so they're like
it's over it's over gloves are off
that's it yeah and so that's the video
that I'm first in I'm in this video
where I play a
secretary at Nintendo breaking the news
that the smos boys have created another
Nintendo video um oh they being Rebels
with it they yeah oh okay I get it I get
I I see the vibe I see the vibe all
right how we got Nintendo sponsorships
after this video came out I have no
idea like that where I'm like oh okay
yeah know people don't really watch
this full circle is best they did they
don't remember that part ex like well
you know they have made some stuff I
mean they they got they got millions of
followers so what I'mma do don't don't
worry about the backlog of what we used
to do don't worry about exactly the
blatant disrespect you know what it
probably was they were like man last
time we kind of revolted against these
people they really went out on us let's
let's just bend the knee we don't need
to fight these people they they B the KN
they wouldn't smoke no more they didn't
want zelder clap back song them clapping
back at smos would have just made more
content so it's like they were kind of
in a bad situation in the first place I
would have loved to have seen a Nintendo
sanctioned clapback song can you imagine
how Corporate and amazing that would be
dis check would be crazy no doubt mamoto
he's
like no doubt so then you go you do the
video goes well so is it a situation
yeah they're like okay we really love
what you did want you to come back for
another one what's what's the next step
before when it gets regular yeah it was
literally that they're like hey you're
great on set um you know years down the
line I find out they liked me on set
because I was one of the few people who
came onto their set not as a fan um and
so I wasn't Fanning out uh which I
realized now I run into this problem
quite a lot where I'm talking to
somebody who is quite important we have
a conversation we talk about I don't
know random things meat pies and and
Brad shout out to dror Strange Love Soo
and then 20 minutes later I'm like so
what do you do and they're like oh I'm
the CEO I'm like oh
no oh after you was all loose with this
you're like oh oh you own the whole
thing I've had many moments like that
Todd Todd Harris um who is the man who
started highes um is a great example of
it this is a man that I was just talking
to in the audience at Smite World
Championships just totally Loosey Goosey
with it I'm like oh what do you do why
why are you
here murder me good that's your
personality that that's that's was any
of them ever so like embarrassing that
you just walked away
like oh we ain't doing this I mean at
that point I think they had already
walked away because of the conversation
I was having you know is what it is no
question so then continue I'm sorry
continue oh yeah but but so yeah I I I
think you know like Ian and I like the
first conversation we had was about like
cars CU he had the Subaru and one of my
favorite cars was like a 98 to 2001
Subaru 2.5 RS and it was like I wanted
that car and he had uh a Subaru and so
we're that's were talking about um not
like hey what channel is this going on
and like what is this for I should have
started with that um but anyway they
liked me on set they're like hey will
you come back tomorrow for you know like
this audition and I almost didn't go
because I'm like why not why go to an
audition when you're a ballerina and
like that's like a career you know it
was 50 bucks oh okay so like you like
this this I don't know like you was more
interested in temp work and they're
trying to kind of like offer you
something more permanent you like well I
already have a permanent thing totally
totally and it's not like I had a job
like I had a career you know what I mean
like I put my full weight into it I've
been doing this as a since I was a kid
it's all I know and so there's no way
I'm walking away from it so um I I go
yeah okay maybe and the next day I'm
like I'm not doing anything I don't have
a gig lined up right now I'm still you
know out of
contract show up and that turns out to
be this
audition I'm thinking it's like gonna be
a a legitimate audition right I come
from theater am like what do I have what
do I need prepared I have my resume what
do you want and it turns out to be this
weird like 20 minutes line of like
questioning like like what would you
bring to a zombie apocalypse what's your
favorite Pokemon
and I'm so aloof man I'm borderline rude
because I'm like what is this what is
this you like what they're probably at
that point because they were considering
bringing you on for more of a per thing
like can we even stand being around in
this individual for a certain amount of
time let's see that before we see
anything what's the extent of any type
of gaming knowledge and just kind of
silly I guess personality kind of
question yeah yeah they're like they're
just trying to see they would click
Personality yeah like like compatibility
I mean if you're making that kind of
content that would actually be way more
important than anything else yeah
totally yeah I think they were just
seeing what sort of outlandish things I
would say or do and like I think I think
the the the line of questioning that got
me the job was they asked have you had
like what's the weirdest thing you've
eaten and um one of the uh characters on
Smash at that point was Ian's pet guinea
pig and I had just gotten back from Peru
and I ate a guinea pig oh
oh my God hey
yo Mr Smiley that definitely got you job
cuz like oh this is going to be great TV
this is going to be so bring Mr smiley
on
set now barbecue go yeah I was
delighted I was delighted to tell this
story of like oh yeah you know that pet
you've got I've eaten its cousin yo
that's wow that's wow I like it though
cuz they like yo this going to be funny
they they they see it how this could
click you know with the crew and having
these story so then that that goes down
I'm sorry finish please please well the
thing is I was second in line because
like I I had not done any production or
anything like that and there was
somebody else that they were auditioning
who comes from broadcast she's already
uh been in front of the camera doing
hosting and interviewing and things like
this um and so I was second
uh in
line um but you know I I found out much
much later um you know just a I don't
know maybe like a few years after I had
gotten hired I'm like why' you guys even
hire
me and apparently the line of thinking
was you can teach somebody to edit but
you can't teach Charisma and that is
very much stuck with me and I'm
extremely grateful oh that's super dope
super dope love to hear stories like
like that especially you know from a
traditional career standpoint there's
still a little a bit of fear you know
I've had this conversation with s
actually you know saying just like you
know content creation and and going into
a space that obviously is brand new you
don't really know about it and then you
know it kind of makes you say you know
what I'm having a good time and
diverting from the kind of the safety
the foundation of what you know right
it's still a scary step like that's
that's not easy and then obviously with
the parents and you know the family
I'm assuming resistance and so like when
is it did you get to the point of
success where or ever does does Mom say
all right I get it now but like did was
it fairly soon or way late in the
process and when when what was the
moment you remember when that was
accepted I you're doing this now it
wasn't awkward at Family reunions
anymore
yeah um I'm waiting for the day um oh
still ain't happen Okay
okay you know I think there was the uh
fear that was input into my head too of
like how could you possibly let go of
the thing that you've been doing for
this long you know like it's a
guaranteed bag yep where are you going
to let go of that and for what something
that has zero track record of ever doing
anything
because was it a traditional household
like do you understand what I'm talking
about as far as the expectations on uh
Eastern culture you like traditional
Japanese household or like what's the
energy pressure that they they put on
the children as because I thought you
was going to say something like Dr first
but and then you know got to the
ballerina stuff so I said oh I really
understand it now and she built it from
scratch and she built it for you and I
just watched that in the movies
Elemental on uh yes I just watched that
and the pressure she was under the fire
element was under because of the father
and he wanted to pass it on was you
under that tremendous type of pressure
do you think yeah yeah and I'm still
under it because you know my mom is in
her late 70s and still not
retiring um and I know that part of it
is that she yes she loves it you know
she this is she built her career off of
this because it is the one thing that
she's always been um you know kind of
not beholden to but like she started
early and she was good at it and now
she's got a whole thing that she's made
she's created an Empire that she wants
to give to me but I I think part of the
reason why she's not retiring is because
in some way she still hopes that holding
out hope yeah that's the whole Crux of
the movie like if y'all ever get a
chance to watch the movie it's very
heartbreaking and she has to find her
way and like you find your way in a
weird way this is kind of crazy because
you go on an interview and you like and
you're probably being rude and that got
you the job being
rude cuz you're like who are these
weirdos and why they ask me these weird
questions and you're not a fan so yeah
that's kind of get dope like I don't
know who you are I don't care about your
14 million like you don't even know like
you just coming in there like whatever
that is the energy different it is
different it was a different energy I I
neged my way into a job so there's
something there the the most horrifying
thing is that this interview this
audition was put on on the internet like
a week
later it must have been that good wait
what was it called called don't tell
it's called worst interview it's called
worst audition ever yo how they that
good it had to be that good in order to
say now we got to air this we can't keep
this for ourselves so that is wild how
you go on an interview and they put your
joint on Front Street and be like worst
interview ever like the sense of you got
to watch it now now is a part I got to
watch that the sense of you is w
it's the bananas part where there I
can't remember like signing off on
anything right like I just showed up and
then it was on the internet with the
caveat they they go hey to our 10
million um subscribers we want you to
tell us who you like out of these I
don't know maybe like five or six people
um and the vast majority was the
audience saying I like Mari she's just
like not trying very hard oh this is
this I'm looking at the video now it has
3 it has 3.4 million views and I'm and
I'm look it's got time stamps and it's
13 years old so that's crazy oh that's
wow so I'm looking I see where she is
and the time stamp is wor uh the
weirdest thing you've ever ate so 3.4
million people know that she's ate a
slug that's dope that's dope I it looks
like it was it was a few people not just
her like they didn't just single okay
I'm like why they just saying it all my
girl
like yeah it was like who do who do you
like out of out of these people they
might just become the third member of
smos yo that's how the box I like that
though how it started yeah I mean I
think it was like one of those things
where it wasn't it wasn't thought out
too much you know like I don't think
they realize what bringing on a new
person meant um but you know they they
brought me on I didn't quit dancing at
that point um I added it on as like job
number four at that point sound like
[Laughter]
s and all at noon he still got the other
three jobs
got grind man that's a grind grind so
you do them both you you when now does
the transition to say all right I I'm
going I'm going to drop this the bag is
up and like is this right is this like
during the whole smash pit weekly is
this during Mari crft like or all that's
after and then you say okay you know
what I can support myself with this yeah
cuz it's one thing to like take a new
hobby up or something it's another thing
to drop something been doing the
security of the of what what what people
consider a traditional bag to say dude
this already happened but the way that
you're asking me is freaking me
out get high anxiety she starting to
doubt her past decision to you got to
break it down for us this is the real
I'm like yeah you're right I did I did
change I did pivot that's scary what
yeah you know it I I wish that I had the
story where I'm like you know what one
one video went out and I just knew and I
pivoted my whole life I wish I had that
story she woke up one day just like I'm
going to wing it be so cool a I want
that
energy um but I I I wanted it
to I think I I would have felt really
embarrassed I think it was an ego thing
if it didn't work out and I had quit the
thing that I was like you know quote
unquote destined to do like everything
was pointing towards this very straight
line dance ballet until my knees died
and then teach ballet and then I die
like that was like my life set up
already yeah yeah very simple and you
didn't like it you wanted the
unpredictability of the
internet I it was my Sega Genesis right
like it was my it was my little
rebellion of like yeah okay I'll I'll
I'll still I'll still go to school I'll
still do ballet I'll still do the thing
and I'm also gonna do this other
thing
villain I love it did they press back
did they push back when you when you
wanted to add that to your routine cuz
they fear it might go that way or were
they okay with you doing all of it at
once I think they didn't understand it
but you know no they were they were
supportive because I don't think that
they they thought it was a hobby like um
I I I would have like a three-page
script that I would write for smos pit
weekly and then I would just try to
remember it as much as I could and then
take forever filming because I'm like I
have to resay the thing resay the thing
resay the thing and it was the of like
jump cuts and really fast editing um and
so I was losing my mind on Friday
evenings filming this thing probably
around like midnight to 3:00 a.m. wow um
and King you asked if if I had a
traditional you know family yes in the
sense that I was not allowed to um live
outside of the home unless I was married
and so until marriage I was gonna stay
with my parents and so at the time I was
24 um and still living at my parents
house um and so I'm I'm and it's not
because you can't sustain your own it's
because that's not going to happen not
allowed yeah no pretty traditional in
that
sense B but what's kind of dope full
circle is that you end up doing a
traditional Japanese wedding which was
super dope I saw that I was like oh
that's super dope but continue story um
and
so so so they they they thought it was
like a like an interesting hobby my dad
was on board more than anything I think
because he comes from like a like a more
of a tech background an electrical
background you know he was just like
what is this new thing he's like do you
see the numbers like oh he saw analytics
he saw the
analytics guy and he's like there's a
million people watching your video and
and for me I'm like I don't understand
what that means I still don't know what
what a million people mean you know like
I know
what five people mean you know like
we're a group of five people having a
conversation this is visceral to me I
have no idea what a million people
looking at something even feels like and
so like to me it's still unfathomable
it's a number that does not compute with
my brain and I and I far enjoy you know
like knowing what this feels like having
ation like this and so I think my dad
you know saw the numbers and he was like
oh this is cool he built me my first hel
prompter homade teleprompter shout to
pop Dukes that's what's up that's
awesome that's what's up I salute at
least at least having that to see the
vision you know well that's Daddy's
little girl yeah but but but that's rare
King cuz traditional household sometimes
and it's like hey you supposed to be
doing this but for for them to have that
understanding nature and his technical
background you got to see me seeing this
movie has gave me a greater
understanding and such a level that is
crazy right now right and the dad no
matter what because I'm like that's with
my daughters daddy little girl if she's
passionate and she knows she has the
conversation that she can have with him
and he sees that passion in in her eyes
he's going to go 100% full board with
her and understand he's going to catch
holy hell from Mom Mom going to be the
barrier in between so that she doesn't
get the full brunt of the holy hell but
you know he's going to help her out and
that sounds so dope it sounds absolutely
dope I I think that you know I have had
a very very fortunate um Journey with
like so like just I just have so many
pockets of like dudes in my life like
really really um
championing me you know and and I think
so much of it like I look for it because
I think that's that's what I saw in my
dad um he he was the president of his
like company and whenever like I would
go on like a a job thing he's like all
right be the boss you know like he would
just say little things like that which
yeah in a lot of ways I'm like I didn't
really see it but like now in the work
that I do I'm like I'm like God like
think I became that because it was kind
of incepted in my head that I'm allowed
to take a position like that
um and and with ballet as a woman you
are cattle there's it was put into my
head that if I cannot if my body cannot
perform there is a hundred other people
just like me that will immediately
replace me um and so I think with ballet
I my worth was tied f fully in in my
body how the shape of it how much I
weighed um the ability of it and nothing
more and when I stepped onto YouTube it
was the first time that I felt like my
worth was tied to my wit my intelligence
what I had to say my point of view and
everything else and that freedom was
intoxicating she wanted something right
now she cooking right now that's that's
real that's real cuz that's the
mentality that is the mentality and um
and thus could see that fuels your
rebellious side cuz you're like I'm I'm
more than this and actually I'm enjoying
doing this and I had this gaming thing
that I got a passion for in conjunction
with it that's super dope yeah
especially nobody wants their life
determined right like you know and
because if you listen to what she said
she said I do this B then I die yeah
like burden of the burden of Legacy man
like of of of maintaining Legacy I I
want to school with a lot of kids that
you know despite coming from you know
very well-to-do backgrounds they were
sort of forced to be whatever their
parents and their grandparents were into
the family business and it's crazy
because you see a lot of those guys now
and of course they they're doing great
they're very well off but they were sort
of they they had to do this thing and
you look at some of them and it's like
you know we're we we're pushing 50 some
of these guys look like they pushing 65
cuz it's the levels of stress of like
you know I didn't get to out and just be
what I wanted to be yeah good point good
point well said I did want to transition
to um where me and addict you know kind
of know you from it's and actually
collaborated with you with uh with aong
the ogog and shout out to the homie
laser K that's my man like as that's as
but he he's such a dope dude like and
what I like he ain't Hollywood us adct
like you some dudes you know bigger
statue sometimes you talk to Big content
creator and you got to get the the hman
you get the nah n n Laser Corn is a real
one salute to laser Corin again yeah I
what's funny is um it was like 2022 the
beginning I think we got Laser Corn 2022
yeah we had laser on yeah yeah at the be
at the end of 2021 it's like I'm blind
emailing people I don't care that's what
we love about over 50 to 60 blind emails
and a few of them got back like Colin
got back yeah um uh you know Laser Corn
got back then I was like I was like man
I was like wants to be on like who's
that bro I didn't know again remember
you got understand Mar like we we the he
the young end of the crew right so he
knows all of y'all like he knows SM he's
been for the ride so we like remember
how you said like with million views
this is wild to me me s specifically
like like why is people watching videos
for like like this is entertaining like
people do it like we not from that era
so it it was kind of like sometimes
people will contact Cog and they're like
oh they want to be on the show like yeah
I don't think that's a good
idea they don't know like the logistics
behind everything I don't know so I'm
like all right I respect it but like
getting back to laser coin I remember
adct was really animate about it and I
was like all right let me do my research
I'm oh they funny like they having fun
it's a good time the Energy's dope and
he came on and we killed it and um cool
yeah he what he say he really he had a
skit called get wck son when he had his
son on the yeah I was like yo this dude
is wild I was like he out here bully
balling his son and game
it's like dunking on your you know
what's even funnier he's like you know
what let's record this it's like playing
basketball with your son dunking on your
son going and record it like yeah get
wrecked son the kid is like okay the kid
going to grow up and then he's he's
going to make his own yeah I was like
you created a monster laser cor you
recorded this this chapter his life when
you dominated him in video games like
you
Wilding it's going to be okay Grandpa
yeah like I'm like bro wait I love you
got to do that to the kids man because
if they beat you in anything I'm telling
you right now my son was beating me in
fortnite I take so much pleasure to this
dat now that I get wrecked son I wreck
yo I think that's one of the greatest
things I've ever seen a parent D like I
was like yo he's wild for this no mercy
for the children yeah so shout out to
lazy
shout out to to Y HOV it's so hinky
obviously we had a great me had a great
show with you so like talk about like
again just just ogog and that
development and rocking on with them
yeah um first off I am surprised that
Lorn uh replied in an email yes the man
is the man's growing up can I say our
boy growing
up what's funny is um I said I can't
remember which one I sent one of the
other ones an email and then when we did
that cab I think last year I I I like
joking called him out he's like oh my
God I'm looking at I don't know how I
missed it yeah cuz to Mar's Point like
we were shocked he actually you know
responded to the email a lot of people's
emails we get it you know what I'm
saying like people are busy to get
thousands of requests stuff like that
but yeah he came through so yeah talk
about that Dynamic obviously a lot from
the old spashing then you know trans
transitioning like what's the energy of
the a
yeah you know okay so the the four of us
for for chat who don't know the four of
us are um the original Smash games
members alongside Ian and Anthony and so
um I we cannot get away from each other
you know you know you got friends you go
through life and and years go by and
yeah yeah these two that's literally I
podcast all of us grew up together for
the most part yeah it's just you you you
you just don't know how to get get away
from one another um and it is an
absolute uh honor pleasure I I just I
love those guys so much um we started on
Smash games um and Ian and Anthony and I
obviously knew each other and those
three guys knew each other and it was
one of those things where all all I can
say is like I don't know when chemistry
happens it just happens it's like I I I
don't I personally don't know about a a
higher power and whatnot is just too big
for me to try to Grapple but I'm like
it's one of those things where it just
feels like kmit right like it just feels
like I don't know why we gel but we do
and from day one I I was just like I
don't know I just like these guys I
trust them and we're good to each other
um and so years years years down the
line it's been what now we're going into
year 11 knowing each other Jesus Christ
that's dope um but yeah the energy is
the same it's the type of thing where um
and I and I'm sure it feels the same for
y all where it's like there is energy
that goes into working with one another
but the the amount of effort is so
minimal you know like you like you you
know that if you're quiet someone's
going to pick up that that that moment
and then you can snatch it away when you
want and then you can give it you know
it's like it's just a a beautiful
Synergy um and you know they they are
they are also the the the folks in the
industry that that really championed me
um in in the
beginning um and continue to do so yeah
salute so many folks salute to the team
a lot of energy super fun and uh yeah
you can see the vibe you can see the
vibe we had a ton of fun and I like
y'all play a lot of games like like
silly little games to get you know mess
with each other and stuff like that and
and that energy comes across on screen
super dope and you know that's kind of
like what IOP is almost found on so your
way of saying we're terrible to each
other you got to mess with your friends
a little bit you know I feel so just
it's just fun you know that kind of yeah
and and I think it does go along with
like this trust right like I I think I
yeah I we've tried to kind of like
workshop and figure out where that comes
from um and and it's probably the hours
that we spent outside of work and like
yeah time and like really knowing what
your buttons are right and then like
being being so close to that button but
knowing when to execute and when not to
and like you know knowing exactly what
the CU okay yeah let's let them calm
down yeah it's more you got internal
calm down and then the clearly their
upset calm down it's it's more the
respect thing
yes and I think when you have respect
for your
comrades uh it's a deeper sense of
trying to know and understand because
with respect comes the understanding
part like you're trying to understand oh
he's having a bad day today like if you
don't respect somebody and they're
having a bad day so so what I'm having a
bad day too you know but you don't see
me acting like that but when you have
respect for somebody you start to
understand them you you try to put
yourself in their shoes so I think that
is like the glue that makes people work
I think you're nailing it I think
respect is absolutely the um it it it's
it's so important and you know and and
like for our Dynamic it was five men and
one girl you
know our our our Flagship show was
called Game Bang
like shout out the game you you can tell
you could tell if you like go back and
listen to she knew exactly where she was
going with yo that's wow that's that got
and sad part is everybody thought it
nobody said nobody said it funny part
she said it I just was like e and I
think sincerely from the GetGo I was on
board because of like you say King
respect was there you know like it
wasn't a degrading thing it wasn't it
was all in fun and on camera and off
camera I I know I'm respected and I'm
heard in a room before before there were
words to be like I need to be seen and
heard you know like it wasn't part of
the vocabulary not even like 10 years
ago I feel like it's a very new thing to
be able to say that I felt that from the
get-go I didn't have to fight my way in
order to be so it wasn't like a Call of
Duty room where you walked in and
everybody voice Chang and they was
trying to help
you
hey that's when you was like you know
what I can rock with these dudes cuz
they're not weirdos yeah they just being
regular they just being regular with the
crew you thinking about it now right
you're the type of voice where I walked
in said hello and they continued playing
their magic
game and I kind of sat there and I was
like so are we working together and and
they're like yeah I think so I'm like
cool can you I'm like can you deal me in
next you know it's like it's it's that
feeling from the GGO rather than like
hello now here not the throw
do you would you like any
water yo I hate them dudes y I get so
upset with it that I just leave yeah cuz
K we look at we like you know you being
extra right now I'm like you know you
don't act like that you know you don't
act like that soon as Mar here now you
won't be different man all I care about
is if you can shoot a gun and you can
call you can make signal call out make
your call out you got to get out of here
that's it facts so salute to that I do
want to transition to space station
which you kind of talked about earlier
you know I you the co-owner Esports
organization you know what I'm saying
which is super dope and um yeah tell us
about that you know obviously um Smite
is a big part of that and um I just
wanted to shout out space station
because again like we talked before you
know as a person who plays Halo infinite
and you know the default skins you kind
of little ashy the ashy Spartans you
know what I'm saying cuz that's that's
people ain't spending no money so I went
right to the store I went to the
microtransaction store kid so you know
me I'm looking for that black and gold
I'm look I need something to represent
me so I was like yo who this space
station they colors is clean my Spar is
glossy F like black gold looking like a
iron LW I was like I'm down whatever
space station doing I'm down with that
so that's why I want the transition like
how did this whole thing start cuz
that's how I learned about it start to
get more in the eort she got the initial
design like that's too ashy we need no
ashy spart shout out to kif I said we
need to start space station in order to
Pander to one man only that's that's it
it was for me reason for the entire
organization it's for one man and she
hasn't announced closing because they
did that I appreciate
y'all so tell a story like how how that
start then you become a owner of it how
does this how does this happen so start
it started I want to say 2017 I should
know this history a lot better I want to
say SSG started in 2017 as a uh love
letter um to Smite the the guys who
started it were always playing Smite in
their office um and they're like hey
let's fire up a team um and so they had
their team later that I me it got it's
got to be maybe like January February
2018 is when I probably saw them at my
world championships that's probably what
makes sense because it's early on in the
year um I saw them there they said hello
I'm like what's what's going on and
they're like we're space station I'm
like cool I'm a fan and so remained a
fan for a very long time until I want to
say maybe like late 2019 is maybe going
into 2020 the owner Sean and I are
talking and I'm like you know I've been
in gaming for a decade I have gotten to
do a lot of things where it's me first
it's my face on things and I've gotten
to have an incredible career being so
selfish um and I don't know what to do
to open more doors I I I just I I don't
have the understanding um on how to do
that and so the more we talked um it we
landed on doesn't make sense for me to
become a co-owner um and to kind of
figure out what other initiatives would
be interesting and to and for full
transparency I'm still figuring out what
that is for me um I think early on I
wanted to start like like female driven
initiatives okay and then the more I
went on I'm like I the more we
categorize
ourselves you know uh women in gaming
women in gaming panels you know like
female uh driven blah I'm like well I'm
the more I am separating ourselves from
the greater gaming community and what
has always bolstered me is not
separating myself but being ingrained in
all of it and so um that for me
personally is changing and I think it is
it's I'm still kind of formulating in my
mind what I can bring to the table in
that sense I I want to be really um
deliberate and thoughtful when it comes
to that because there's just so many
things now where it's just like yeah
it's a checkbox you know like how many
how many checkboxes can we put in oh
you're a personal color wonderful all
right we got that yo that was wild I
like she gave it a real
we did that with the show we got a we
got we we got all the damn we just
need then we can check all the boxes we
check all Mari whenever you ready it's
the 10
million you know what would be
crazy be crazy like as like a diverse
panle if we did have like weem Asian it
would literally be
everyone it work I I love her honesty
with that cuz yeah it's real I'm but I I
noticed that like like women in gaming
right and I and I don't like it goes
back to that
whole when they come inside the room
right right it goes back to that idea
because if they keep saying um am I seen
as a woman in gaming no you my I don't
care if you're a woman a man or what
just can you shoot the gun right like
can you shoot it's nothing worth
having uh somebody that's tagging along
in a raid in Destiny and they can't play
right then we have to find a we have to
find a little corner for them to sit in
right you you like you sit right here do
nothing when you get to the point where
You' rather them do nothing than do the
littlest job then it's bad that's that's
the problem so my thing is is it was
never about you know are you a girl or
are you a guy it was always about can
you game yeah what is your skill level
yeah and and I noticed that it it got to
a point where it was like all girls and
then guys and then and I noticed when I
started talking about it when I started
saying hey guys oh and girls I had to
say and girls but I when I initially
said it it was just all inclusive yeah
you just got to a point where now it
started to be separate like I must say
this because oh I'm just talking about
the guys no I was talking about all of
us we all guys I don't care we all guns
like like you said King it was just more
for us it was more like okay can you
play are you passionate about it that's
it like once those two critor is B I
don't we don't care what's going on and
we never it's weird like we never had
that energy even when you're young and
you're like oh girls playing video games
or whatever like like I remember I do
you remember how excited we were when we
first saw Tomb Raider yes and and it
wasn't in none of it was never about oh
my God look at what what she's wearing
or whatever that's just weird like
polygons it was like oh my God she's
running around in 3D that's all we cared
about no my thing was when she did the
the the ballerina flip up oh yeah cuz
she had the full ballerina thing Swan
and then you Swan Dive and killed Her
Off
K I don't know I'm just I'm just a weird
gamer when it came to that I just looked
at us as all one collector cuz we was
nerves cuz it was everybody against us
right all all the cool people against
the
nerv so it didn't matter what you were
white black whatever come on ner yeah
it's like oh you a gamer in this click
that at the time ain't socially really
accepted so we you you part of us we
theit we we got we got to take care each
other yeah cuz you speak my language got
peanut butter and jelly I got T fish
factual no that's that's what's up
that's what's up I to totally agree and
I love you know your honesty as far as
the space and what's going on and and I
was just the last question I had to
reference to it was just like you know
do you see you know as far as like the
future of Esports and this thing
continue to grow and like I'm a person
that you know I used to play
competitively you know it's before any
type of you know tournament stuff but I
used to play like Tekken competitively
and stuff like that and you seeing
what's going on now and it's like teams
and organizations and I'm like oh this
is real money the crowd yeah like the
money like the crowd in one of these
shows shout out to my man Jason Jacobs
in the uh Esports law that we've had on
good friend of the realm and like I went
to like a Cod event and I'm seeing the
teams go at it and it's an energy I have
never seen in a crowd and I think you
made a a comment Mari which was like
going to like an event is like a picture
like a a baseball game where every in is
bottom of the knife Bas is loaded and
it's the crowd is on the Edy for
everything because they're so
knowledgeable and so passionate like
what do you see about the future of
Esports and where this thing potentially
could be going I mean I think I think
gaming in in general is still in its
infancy we have a 50y year like history
it's the only history that I feel like I
have any grasp of because it's short you
ask me about European history I don't
know I don't know what they did back
then it goes back a million years I
don't know I can't I don't have a
grapple of it that that's what makes us
feel old Mari cuz we could say we were
there from the beginning that's sad it's
great and sad at the same time oh my God
it's not sad at
all magic
yes about the age sham no they they they
a sh me all the time we ain't about that
BR it's sad it's sad they old they ow
they ow no when she said that she had a
famicom show up in house
famicom see that's crazy different
that's that's that's the Genesis of it
like you know not even use that pump
that's that's it because when I brought
a famicom and I and I brought it
straight to Cog I got to bring it
straight to C and I love the shape of I
hate the American shape of I hated the
American shape the the Japanese shape of
it was so Sleek it was so dope the
cartridges even look better and like
this is it and I know you had that same
feeling when you saw it you was like
this is mine and to hell with my
brother yeah it was it's just a what
what a magical time where it was The
Fringe thing right like it was like all
of a sudden these uh coin op arcade
things are in people's houses it changed
it changed people and it's continuing to
still change people um but it's such a
rich Short history I mean what 1972 when
pong was like like you know given to us
oh my gosh and the whole history is so
crazy because it wouldn't have gaming
gaming wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
World War II and like the the technology
that came out of it like technology that
went into building the atom bomb is in
what we we see as gaming you know it's
like it's such a crazy Short History um
but with that said I think Esports is
like it is a little tiny baby yeah we've
seen the uh you know uh being on Wall
Street and and in the the crazy big uh
Arenas uh we've seen you know kids with
with Lambos and all this stuff
I I think that that is an aspect of
where Esports has been I I do think that
there's a flux that's happening a little
bit a little bit like the 83 gaming
crash I want to say I think that there
is an idea of consumer distrust right
now happening overall with new things
whether it's crypto or nfts or AI we're
being pumped with oh this thing is new
this thing is new and so therefore
there's money and it's shiny and you
want to get in it who wants to invest
come in and that's right and I think
that there's a little bit of like
there's an inside joke going on here if
you yeah don't worry about me and King
having a solid War
continue yeah don't worry about don't
worry about us don't worry about us it's
about it's about the AI
yeah okay
okay we don't want to Der story King is
trying to derail the train yeah yeah
don't worry this is not about us right
now this is about Mari
continue see she's about the chaos and
the unpredictability of it and the fact
that they kept saying this this this
that's not not going to fly with her
it's not in her DNA she
Lov go don't look over there go no I'm
looking now I can't stop looking what
are we looking
at let's do
it no no good points good points in
reference to the sports I think that
that we're still figuring it out I think
that uh you know the the I think
audiences and consumers are just way too
smart to be like here's your food just
eat it they're like no what's in the
food Ag and I think that's what's
happening right now with Esports as a
whole of like okay let's can we dissect
it a little bit what's in our food oh
how much like where is this money going
where is it coming from um and and like
how do consumers and audience members
fit into it are we just a commodity um
you know can we be more than that and
why are we just this you know so I think
there's a lot of questions happening as
they should be happening and I think
that that's why there's a lot of like uh
um flux happening in gaming in general
and Tech in general it kind of goes like
that makes sense makeing sense and uh
it's a couple look like one or two more
questions I had to ask you with
reference to look in the entertainment
space you've got a lot of accolades
you've done a lot I mean you were on
Survivor like like like you were on
there about it all the time like Netflix
you know fighting choreography like your
list of accolades hosting all the things
so out of everything what is your like
what are your personal we the magic
moments where you like yo that was super
dope that was super dope when we did
this when I did that you know what
stupid the the the first thing that
comes up is literally
like being in the office playing games
with the guys like that that's it's
stupid because it is the least stripped
down like it is the most stripped down
thing it's the least flashy thing I feel
like the correct answer is like when Jin
and I got to go to Egypt oh I saw that
that was fine y'all was in the pyramids
for real for Assassin's Creed an hour
and a half inside the Great Pyramid of
of Giza it was for
Origins or ourselves they cleared they
cleared the pyramid for us to just be
idiots inside of there yeah like it
makes no that's the correct answer did
you did okay so
okay low thinking is hell she how did
she survive that being un being what's
word I'm looking for being un
unsupervised
unsupervised in the
pyramid so my my question my question
did you feel energy because they say
like all right cuz I'm I was supposed to
go before the pandemic I was supposed to
go everything was supposed to be but we
supposed to go to Egypt and then this
thing happened and it derailed it and
then life hasn't been the same and I've
been trying to get back there but did
you feel like
energy going into the pyramid around the
pyramid how did you feel like as
yourself because I know you had Quiet
Moments especially in there this it's
the one of the seventh greatest
structures in the world so like what was
your feelings when you was alone in your
thoughts yeah I I I feel like there is a
great importance to to focusing on One
Singular thing and it but but I I don't
think to to answer your question
directly an energ I don't think I felt
an energy but I think that might also be
I wasn't looking for it right like I I
think that I am a person where I don't
um have the audacity to to be like I am
one way or another when it comes to
spirituality I think I'm like I'm a big
dummy I don't know
anything and and so I think I wasn't
necessarily looking for that I just know
that it is a great big
Monument a lot of people sacrificed
themselves for it to make it it
has I mean it
lasted the you know this whole lifespan
of so so so many um generations and it
still is there I like there's something
incredibly special about it I don't
think that there's anything that we're
building now that will withstand itself
the way that it has like that is yeah
yeah it kind of like makes you think
about like permanence and sort of like
temporary stuff and for me like it helps
me just let go of like um getting bogged
down with like like my own ego probably
and being like what is the what is the
Legacy I I leave
behind you know you're not leaving a a
pyramid behind
right I'm like what is lasting and I'm
like you know I think it helps me let go
and helps me realize that you know like
I can be serious about my work and still
not take myself seriously um which I
like to apply to to a lot of things
that's super dope I salute to you I mean
to see that and I saw you went over in
and there and um that was funny she was
like I think he was talking about like
how it smell and was making that and
then you're like yo look how long we got
to climb this thing and I'm just like yo
did I think it was like a Circ confence
something y'all was looking at it's like
it was just y'all would have a to your
point trying to be Tomb Raider y'all
trying to be I was trying to be
knowledgeable and you know not piss off
the BBC guy that was letting us in I was
like trying to be respectful and Jin's
like like like what am I I'm a mommy you
know
like
absolute so you know I mean that's I
think that's kind of our
um you guys you guys left and he was
like Americans man Americans I know and
then I'm like I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
apologizing learn Arabic I'm so sorry
that's super dope no last thing all you
know we kind of support the the health
is wealth lifestyle one thing I see a
respect that you're doing out there you
doing your little training you're doing
your your hit you know training and
stuff like that and uh clearly you like
burpees we talked we got talk about the
burp oh that's the greatest exercise
ever is the burp this is Lady
burp so why is that why is the health as
wealth uh mindset that I why is this
important um okay well let's start with
the burpees because I feel like this is
this is like quintessential me whenever
you know everyone sees burpee is like
the most terrible part of it like you
don't you don't uh you don't look
forward to it so I always end with
burpees because I'm like I got to get
out of the
mentality um so yeah I just play around
with
that uh gosh physicality I think I mean
it's kind of it's it's in there because
of ballet and what okay I got a
backtrack way way way way back of like
ballet and I know of like talk trash on
ballet but at the same time it has given
me like the fortitude to know in my head
that I'll get any job done like it
absolutely it's in my DNA that like no
matter what the show goes on I will get
it done no matter what and like it's
given me a lot um abolute and I think
that it's set me up for wellness for my
entire life you know um I'm just seeing
it differently now because in ballet it
was all about just for me me personally
for my body type just staying as skinny
as possible um it was the era where it
was still legal to um be weighed at work
every week wow wow that's real you're
about you know the reason why I get I
get AA when I go to the doctor so could
you imagine when you going to to work
every week and they like nah man you put
on three lounds business got watch those
Doritos I'm doing too much this week you
off
off or you're off your count that's
crazy that's salute deari
with it was back in that era where it's
like if you're off enough and then
you're you're like you're fired like you
don't have a job anymore and so yeah
yeah it was still legal back back when I
was um you know fulltime uh it sound
like the NFL yeah cuz it's like it sound
like the NFL man up if you get injured
we don't care somebody else is going to
take your spot what is your weight this
week that is NFL
talk wow yeah yeah so um I think coming
from that I think Wellness is always
just kind of going to be in My DNA but
now you know I really got to got to hand
it to to new generations cuz I love that
it's like strong is skinny now and I'm
like so I'm just trying to I'm trying to
get my Boulder shoulders you
know I respect that
go in the building you already know like
T2 Sarah Conor you know I'm going for
get off did can you talk a little bit
about the fight choreography stuff yeah
yeah um action movies always been my
favorite um you know I shout out to the
raid coming out in 4k next
week actually you know I just recently
watched that for the first time oh my
God that's
yeah I liked it it was good I I love
that movie yeah the fight the fight
sequences in the radar it was Game of
Death on steroids yeah like yeah got to
get upstairs like it's
crazy so yeah I think um YouTube showed
me the pathway of like well No One's
Gonna you know bring you contracts and
give you work on a silver platter you
got to go get you got to go get it and
so I'm like oh okay yeah I want to do
action stuff so I'm not going to wait
until Hollywood's like hey Mario we've
been looking for you for like I'm just
going to start learning on my own and
start making short films and and stuff
like that and uh one of the huge reasons
why I moved to Vegas in general um is
because some friends out here are
Shaolin uh Kung Fu guys who also do
stunts and they're the folks that we
first collaborated with on an Assassin's
Creed yet another Assassin's Creed uh
thing that I pitched a long time ago
where it's like hey can we just do the
fight scenes from the game and that was
an RFP for you for Ubisoft and it went
through and so that's how I got to know
these guys and so now I just bug them
I'm like hey can I do a sequence where I
beat you guys up even though I can't in
real life
thank respect super dope super dope no
doubt and then the final question we ask
everyone in the realm with tradition I
need lady mari's top five video games or
friend ches of all time no pressure I
love it no pressure no pressure um in no
particular order and just going off of
my head um I'll probably miss out on a
on a ton I'm going to say Fallout New
Vegas oo obsidian in the building love
that it's the best Fallout game best
Fallout game coside add coside best
Fallout game Goat talk let's go um
Minecraft yes Mari craft of course yeah
it's it's it helped me build my career
and then and although I'm not actively
playing now I think it's one of those
games where I'm like I got to give it a
shout out for the rest of my life um
dope that's Tope God just five um I'm
gonna say
rdr2 oh is in love sa is in love you
you're definitely allowed to come back
yeah you're always welcome
man Red Dead I got a throw in GTA 5 Okay
yeah I'm sure you played a lot of that
game that's the one right five is the
last one oh five is the last one I
thought okay my bad I got it confused I
got
confus the chaos the chaos one chaos
chaos the W one with the three protect
okay got you got you got you okay uh
just one more one more one more you know
we can always oh God no oh no okay I'm
now in my in my head I'm thinking of all
sorts of wacky things
um this oh I I think tell me a week
later and I won't put this in in here
but it's probably I'm going to put
stardew
Valley well it's a very new one for me
that's probably out of the list the
newest one on on the list for me but um
it is a game that I've been playing with
my nephew night after night and um when
he
is tired of having to have to be so
sweaty playing fortnite and cod with his
friends it is like like he's it's it's
his little therapy game and I
it reminds me of why gaming is so
amazing because we have these deep talks
about school and growing up and things
like that whilst having games as our
background and I think that that has
played a huge role in my life of like
this safety net of like oh I got to go I
I can you know rip the the the the the
safety Court out if I want but until
then I'm going to stay here and just
have like like talks that need to have
talks and I and I feel like I've had a
lot of those moments while playing games
with friends that's doe um and I'm just
seeing it in a different generation so I
love it for that oh that's super dope
the chat is is is a little upset though
they said has she got the the 117 look
like
the and and the helmet in the back and
they like we ain't hearing no she just
like she like good she like good posture
stop playing
around wait is this a is this a
reference to something I mean it do look
like it's a it with
[Music]
something I'm just messing with you you
put them on fire in the CH so much Halo
Stu actually this is also a um Master
Chief this is one side of Master Chief
and the other one on this side and it's
supposed to look like um God and Adam
doing
this doing this but it's with uh it's
with a yeah do Master Chiefs honorable
mention honorable mention I I I I feel
the heat I feel the heat I'm sorry you
they roasted you
hard but you know I got to go with the
ones that are emotional I went with my
with my emotions and respect the that
don't forget to cop the merch over
in Halo
go make sure smart look good no doubt
and final uh F I think I don't answer to
this but I'm still curious favorite
console of all time and
why I'm going to say Genesis um and
that's another it's another emotional
answer honestly I I um got my hands on a
Genesis uh not too long ago for Marcus
brownley uh video that I did with him
and I was like and I was like wait is
this like a emulator and he's like no
he's the real thing I'm like did the
controller feel this light and
cheap yes in my hand a kid that thing
was massive heavy it felt it felt
expensive
and now I'm like oh yo this feels like a
toy it's different no doubt salute to
Lady Mari in the realm giving us that
beautiful gaming history still hanging
out with us for a little bit you know
what I'm saying so we got some topics
real quick no question and then add you
think we need to do that thing that we
supposed to do talkad mute your mics
yeah everybody mute your mics and the I
mean we don't have to mute our mics
he'll mute us I'll be but yeah we got a
little little surprise little little
something we getting excited for check
it
out welcome to beautiful Hawaii as we
await the latest installment in the
Yakuza series like a dragon infinite
wealth with all man our Underdog hero
ichon kazaka the legendary hero of
Yokohama teaming up with everyone's
favorite the legendary dragon Asam makir
you and all the favorites that's coming
back we got The Lovable homie cop hchi
you know what I'm saying we got Jun
guihan smoo assassin and our hostess
with the mostess Sayo Namba it's so many
people coming back as well as a new
casting characters and we're going to
see what's going on as we play some of
the best inter turn base combat goodness
mini games heartfelt story and of course
you know when it get sticky you got to
call the pound mates man
if it go crazy you go hit the submits
them kab submits it's gonna get crazy we
out here and we're ready to see what is
going on in this latest epic story and
here we go January 26 2024 it's coming
out Playstation Xbox Windows steam
pre-order now get the heroes booster
pack special job set before it's too
late for more information visit infinite
wealth. sega.com and look I can't stay
too long I got to get over to dondu
Island um I don't know if you heard cuz
I'm building out my little Taurus hot
spot my personal situation going on over
there so I'm going catch y'all later
peace ah Welcome To Paradise
[Music]
hello all right I can show you around
now there's a few things you need to
learn before we have a good time it's
Yahoo
you can have a little fun with some
friends you even pick up a new
skill whatever you do be
careful even Paradise could have his
secrets you trying to tell me there a
Yakuza in Hawaii not exactly something
you'd find in a guide book is it keep
your friends
close and your enemies closer names dght
nice to meet you take
cover no doubt you already saw it here
first that uh look promo with the Lord
respect y I just came back for the beach
y I just came back it's crazy czy flew
out there for a whole two days y that
infinite wealth is crazy you know how it
go you know what I'm saying go check
that out yo link is in the description
somebody said IOP is brought by Sega
they were yo y' if you guys like turn
Bas man there ain't no reason you ain't
playing that game no question link the
links in the description use that link
support the channel appreciate y'all
shout out to the good friends at Sega
rgg and All That infinite wealth coming
soon you already know that's our first
Sega sponsor yeah little little promo
promo no doubt you already know so we do
you know anything that we don't know
about Sega and
Microsoft no comments no comment sir no
com make sure we make sure we get that
street to ra
code that's what I want all the that's
what we want just radio just radio no
doubt all right so let's get into the
poll last week's poll results are in and
the people have spoken with rumors of an
exp box next in 2026 what do you think
is the best approach for the future of
Xbox the winner of the four-way ILP poll
at 43% was launch Xbox next and dictate
terms of the New Gen massive game lineup
they definitely agree with King on that
one tied for second place at 24% of the
vote was uh both Stan Pat because you
have the games with Xbox game studios
ABK and Bethesda Punk talk
and I don't care don't give high-fi rush
to switch in PlayStation group that was
tie that was tie for second and then
last place 8% of the vote was do a mid
Generation update to match the PS5 Pro
instead group shout out to all the
people in the realm who voted king um
the people seem to agree with you they
they want Xbox to set off the the next
gen 2026 2027 you that's right no soft
talk Sundays no mustard heart
Mondays we will put the chicken hearts
to the back and we will take the front
line in advance we will dictate pace and
make sure that they can't keep up great
games new hardware and we'll start the
gym when we say
so then a year later the Sega Dream
Castle all over a I like this kid I like
that song come captain pesimistic at his
finest please sir this had nothing to do
with you your contingent of mustard
Hearts must I'm going have bued all over
that
pause so let's move into the P questions
shout outo we got two super oh get super
super chat get Super Chat first we got
the legendary Yi AKA Dragon heart yobi
$5 Super Chat sounds like Mari needs to
be a regular or an honorary IOP member
she's hilarious and legit
that's super dope we welcome obviously
no question what else we got let me see
that we got ah
sagging nut sack superat man these names
bro two pound Super Chat finally
watching Live question for King later
okay nut sack got something for you he
got self nut got s King
latero read the chat
s you don't want that later okay we
got you don't like that about that
got nothing for me
later legendary Yi again $5 Super Chat
hash peace love life to the Lord's
acquiring inquiring minds want to know
your thoughts on Nintendo Mari I think
Mari gave her thoughts on Nintendo I
think she gave her thoughts yeah yeah
besides
oh oh yeah yeah yeah okay yeah I think
she did okay cool we let's see what else
we got Astro parrot King I I I think I
know what this was talking we were
talking about how I think we were
talking about Nintendo and it's like
restrictions um
ah yeah yeah because we were talking
about uh copyright and stuff like that
um my my take on it is
like okay gaming history going back to
like the 83 crash basically this
happened because V like console games
were at an all-time high Atari what
didn't have any licensing uh
restrictions for third party games so
anyone in anything like anyone who
wanted to make games could make games so
much of these games were not working and
consumer trust plummeted people stopped
buying consoles blah blah blah it
crashed it only came back up because
Nintendo was super super restrictive
they like only let uh certain people
publish with them and they had uh
restrictions on how long they could
publish with them which is two years
they had to be on board for two years or
something like that they controlled the
cartridges
the everything they controlled what box
art looked like they had their stamp of
approval on it um they single-handedly
made people believe in games again
because they're like oh cool these games
actually work they're delivered as as
they said that was going to be and now
we're not foolish for buying games and
so in a lot of ways yes Nintendo gets a
lot of flak for being really restrictive
on things whether it's from the fighting
game um perspective and that Community
or
um uh taking down YouTube videos and
whatnot they get a lot of flack for it
but I also understand that they're
coming from the perspective of what
worked before and I think there's still
an importance to it that we often times
forget well well said well said
especially the history right we forget
the the role Nintendo did play
standardizing legitimizing the quality
SE great great points that that's
actually agree with you though I I do
think that the consumer trust for the
gaming industry is probably going
straight to the lowest it's ever been
like yeah what is it days days
before yeah you know and it's like that
I think that is a it was a is a crypto
rug little hust in our in our little
Community you know and it's like whoa
get these bad guys out of here um good
point good point but I think it's opened
the door for you know and not to say
that Indie publishing isn't good or you
know anything like that but it has
opened the door um for people to be able
to publish on their own um make games on
their own you know we have all the
technology um given to us and going back
to ai
ai busts an entire huge door into that
of like you're not an engineer hey you
can still build a game
um and it's like hey you're not a
publisher you can Kickstart the game so
there's like there's all these Avenues
of being able to create games that may
or may not work and I think that it's
only going to make us have to be savier
um and and there's going to be more of
those like heartbreaks just like days
before Oh my God you brought that up
easy nice yeah it's good point though
she she she spoken out here the wound is
still the wound is fresh the wound is
fresh it still hurts super CH soon yeah
we have a AST parrot King remember Lord
bronze I'm my mama on my hood hold on on
my hood my IP brothers look fly my I
brothers look good touch their swag wish
you
could have a a got 225 front squat type
of day shout out to the front squat
shout out no doubt then we have let me
see J JD gamer $2 Super Chat pathetic
Port begging PlayStation fans got no
games oh oh go he busted his he busted
his gun early his console guns keep
going don't stop like what did I join I
see I see Xbox front line in here such
objectivity from JD G such
objectivity Bal
perspective don't don't shame any of my
troops keep
going keep
going D G5 that again Mario is great
giving us the road map to success and
gab shout out to the Lords for always
Landing the best interviews in gab keep
it up thank you brother salute salute JD
you already know you know what's funny
they don't know we've actually had this
in the books for like what six months oh
yeah yeah absolutely I appreciate it
everybody's showing up and showing love
all right we got just two patreon
questions we get into topic uh Diago
padra he says uh hello Lords hope you
all had great vacations I want to bring
us subject to the
paast paast assuming that the creatures
in pal world will be called Pals uh is
it the main mechanic of the game
throwing balls at your future
Pals how about the name of said balls
pal balls will we get messages of
running out of pow balls will we get
messages of you Mr your pow ball I'm
sorry but this game needs a big pause
give me your thoughts on the matter and
what is your expectation of this
upcoming game pass game have a blessed
Sunday okay when I first saw this game
uh you could not tell me we didn't get
Pokemon ins our Game Pass yeah it felt
like Pokemon with guns I said but then I
saw guns I said wait a second Pokemon
with guns Pokemon with
slavery cannibalism wait wait out
Pokemons are slaves
so don't act like we don't know what's
happening over there overt that in this
game there are literally sweat shots for
the Pokemon this is the over the top
version not the sweat shot for the this
is if Genesis made
Pokemon yeah Pals could be this is the
description Pals can be used to fight or
they can be made to work on farms and
factories you can even sell or eat
them survival in a harsh environment
where food is scarce and vicious poaches
roam Danger waits around every corner to
survive you must tread carefully and
make difficult choices even if that
means eating your own Pals when the time
comes this is the description of
sometimes sometimes you got to get past
the winter you know you know what this
is don't you this is how Pokemon would
be if it wasn't PG yeah if Nintendo if
Nintendo did not have their hand on this
is Nintendo they didn't put they seal do
do they have any guinea pig pal I can't
you know what I think this propaganda
for chickens because we do this with
chicken we make them [__] fite we eat
them we make them work on a farm and
make sure they get all the worms and all
the all the stuff like that we we do all
these and we keep them as pets this is
just propaganda for the
chickens this is like like waterers Shi
down like turned around on us animal I
actually think I'm going to play this
game pal po world is outside so yeah
that I guess that's what we think Theo
don't they call that don't they call
that game Pokemon with guns yeah Pokemon
with guns I have a feeling this is going
to be a big game I don't even know the
actual name I just Pokemon guns yeah
power world power world that's what it
is I don't even think that that was the
original like tagline isn't that what
just just Jeff Keeley said at uh Fest
and like literally no one was paying
attention they're like okay yeah another
Trailer World premiere great and he goes
it's Pokemon with guns goes what yeah
they they got the
attention
how bet you Nintendo had a season the
set yeah Nintendo Nintendo going to be
outside this one yeah cover the Game
Pass see what's going on there Jeff Jeff
was going to get the announcement for
the next switch but after that he like
no can't do that pulled it live on a
can't do that uh oh s someone wants to
talk to you in Super Chat JD gamer $50
Super Chat shout out to you brother
microsof hear me I need you to not look
at the spreadsheet and make a decision
with your heart
that is the only way to succeed in the
consumer space it's what's always been
missing with Microsoft consumer products
it is the uh the magic that captures
hearts and Minds so this was he he
cosigning power what are he going I
guess he he's cosigning just signing
blank checks and not you know not not
not adhering to the rules of
business say Microsoft flight simulator
keep pumping them out even though no one
them
Microsoft forget about the analytic he's
saying pay $6 billion for 6 GTA 6
exclusivity that's what he saying Oh
okay that's what this is that's what
this is all right one last uh patreon
question using that it's a little long
so I got to
abbreviate he's spitting hope all is
well with the ls in the chat also hope
everyone had a relax you safe holiday
break let's start the year off strong
with a bit of a fun question Xbox has
been criticized in the past with The
Narrative of Halo gears and Forza being
their uh really only pillars as far as
established IPS he said well now that
Xbox has all these new IPS my question
is if the laws had to choose three new
pillars that could reach the same level
as gears or Halo so he said to make this
more interesting I want to limit it to
just IP that Xbox owns and is currently
licensed and these IPS cannot have more
than three games currently in the series
so he says games like Elder Scrolls
Fallout and doom or something can't
count right so there's been two games
for Doom okay yeah he said yeah to the
room there three technically no no we're
talking about Xbox okay yeah he said but
if the franchise is all they own it all
they pretty much own yeah the potential
of being rebooted such as Fable or maybe
even quake as just two examples um he
said where distin enough from the
original then you count yeah you can
count those he said apologize for the
longer question just a bit of fun and
start off so what are we going to make
the three new tent poles the the three
new big make Big Mac large fries in
shape like how gears Forza and Halo was
what's what's the three what we going
with any thoughts Mari can go first
mari's going first all right what you
want to make is the three new tent pole
franchises Xbox IPS we're going power
world boys let's go power world
okay that's
what that's that's a joke answer
there were so many rules to the to the
question no more than three games
a and Microsoft owns them yeah three
Xbox I they have to own the IP the IP
okay okay all right I got mine all right
thr your no I was I thought I thought
Mari was going first oh okay my fault
did we did we put pressure on it's open
open whoever want to jump in okay so I I
would say um I know this is gonna be
unpopular but I would say see a thieves
M okay I would say grounded oh we went
two live Services damn love
grounded okay
grounded and
[Music]
um I I want to say a v because I really
really I really think of V because I got
when I saw it it just took me back to a
space and it really took me there so I
really have super high hopes for it and
I think I think it's going to do what
it's supposed to do this week so I'm
going say V so got some good ones hold
on we got de HD and there she saying
Fable hellblade and Psychonauts got
slow-mo in the building hellblade Fable
out of Worlds all right all right all
right what what about you adct what you
going with I'm curious I'm going say
Fable I knew that F was thieves okay
okay live service got the single player
and what's one hell blade blade oh blade
o we doing the Marvel okay but they
don't own the IP yeah they own IP yeah
yeah he he literally said licens IPS in
the thing he say he said no you may be
right he said IP strong established
IPS yeah no license no license no
license so one
more no we I'll say out of Worlds out of
Worlds all right slow that's a good one
fun game I'm I want to throw cuz we
could count hellblade right even though
there was one there was only one in the
series I'm yeah I'm going with Cent one
I'm going with Center one I think yeah
that that's their hashtag just one so to
speak give it to us a sequel so we got
that
um I'd like to see a thieves from a
foundational standpoint and live service
I want to get that that category taken
care of and the third one yeah I gotta
go I got to go something obsidian I
agree they guys so much I love out the
worlds a v looks like
[Music]
potential G my cuz damn AOW looks dope
though I know say AOW is I feel like the
outer worlds already had a game had so
it's easier to Captivate on the success
right and people really like out and
people like the trailer for out of
Worlds too gun to my head out of Worlds
G got man out words because that's like
the you know the new Fallout in a way
because we don't know how long we gonna
get Fallout
from it's all right that's what go with
solve did you get to go no all right so
I'm going go I'm going go an RPG a
shooter and a third person game what I
want to see that's how you roll that's
how you roll up so I I got to agree with
you guys on AOW I think AOW has the
opportunity to be fill that Elder Scroll
sort of pillow yep okay without without
it taking 10 years between
games shout out to God Howard be
respectful shout out to God Howard um I
gotta say I want to see a quake comeback
Quake Quake I've been dying for that
quake come back I definitely want to see
that and then the third person I might
be wrong about this because I know they
don't own they don't own the entire IP
but I I would say t true oh you want
Activision to resurrect okay okay okay
okay go back and do tenu all over I
think they have the rights of the first
two if I'm not mistaken killing us they
saying nobody ain't saying high five
Rush ain't nobody saying Starfield we
talking about pillar
pillar yeah somebody say high five Rush
especially when it's speculation that he
might be a turn Co he might be a
turn we know we got to find out what his
true colors is oh they we got to see if
they loyal they on the front line and
Starfield we don't know if starfields a
one and done we don't know if
that's 25 years from now I mean we get
but we getting shoted space DLC this
they're adding to it but that's what I
mean I think I think I think the
opportunities they see with Starfield
are more almost like service game where
they so you consider it almost like open
world like a live service in a way cuz
they could to just add to that one add
to that one world and keep improving it
fair enough fair enough we going to
change up how you get powerups though
because it's getting really boring yeah
yeah I agree I agree no doubt and then
Mari did you get your your other two
because you I think you got your three
in or uh no I didn't get any of them in
power world is not one of them for the
rest you never know it blows
up um I'm a going I'm going to say say I
too love
Fable and and I think that Fable has the
the potential to have like a high-fi
rush type of drop you know like a shadow
drop and people would just run to it um
I I I think it's got that potential and
the hype even though people I don't know
I I often forget about it and I'm like
oh yeah it's coming yes I'm ready so
um I like that can I can I throw in
Minecraft yeah technically yeah it's
it's an old
I is one game right yeah that's it yeah
cuz I feel like you know I I think of
Halo in the way that like cortana's just
on my computer I don't know what Cortana
is doing but it's like it's it's such a
there like do you want to talk to
Cortana I'm like not really I think I
know where my files are but like the way
that it is integrated so well into their
product I can see Minecraft being one of
those those pillars of like oh Do you
want to build and craft something you
know it's like I that good point yeah
yeah and then they've had like spin-offs
since then the legend stuff and Shout
out we interviewed Craig lay on defining
Duke and reference to that no that's a
good point yeah it is foundational so
you got those two and it was one more
after that um as much as I wish that it
was grounded cuz I absolutely love I
love grounded shout out toan love
grounded um unless that they're doing
some you know some massive multiplayer
type of stuff I don't think that it's
got the potential okay um I'm going to
say I'll I'll throw in see of Thieves
all right see of Thieves no question
yeah salute love the pillis salute to
Diego and we get to the topics finally
and I'm sorry two more Super chats real
quick we have JD gamer again $2 Super
Chat continue dot dot dot before you put
Xbox games on PlayStation don't do it
this is the continuation to the $50
Super Chat okay then we got JD gamer
again $5 Super Chat continue dot do do
and yes Microsoft do what it takes to
drop that bag to get GTA 6 is an
exclusive in any other games the I can
come up
with you know JD gamer is definitely one
of those people that texts that just
instead of like having one big text of
all your opinions he just keeps
repeating another text yeah he's giving
you that that string with the numbers
and Dot do and and one more thing salute
to J at least just's give him at least
one outlandish purchase that'll never
happened oh that's what he want he was
acquisition I I want Sega that's all I
care about I want Sega
that's that that that right there who
you want I want Square
Unix soft uh King is I don't know I
don't know whatever at this point you
know what I want the most outrageous
thing they could do is buying take two
yeah grab grab give me give me crystal D
and Laura cross okay okay he said
pa
pause they have to they have to come
over together they got to come it's a
package deal yeah you want a package um
pause guy PA
Ong pause yeah he different he's
different um I would say Square because
I think Square breaks their back okay
okay you you want Final Fantasy You Want
Blood You Want Blood you want you want
Twitter to just
collapsed that's what you want yes I
want hell I want fire I want Brimstone I
implode and then explode I I want to
look at my DMs and say I've never seen
that number y yo
the the rumored announcement would
implode and then when it's officially
announced it would just blow up all they
they are officially the wealthiest
company on the planet now they did say
they're not finished with
Acquisitions is it is it bad that my
answer is I don't want them to like I I
think competition is like needed and I
think the more that there things are
being gobbled up by bigger folks it's
just like cool we're gonna be ending up
with one I don't know I I just I I I
feel like more competition is better I
no more no more Acquisitions I say fight
harder I say throw him in a deep end if
he can't swim he dies he dies I can't I
can't I also say this while also being
like please take all of my money you
know what I mean it's like it's it's
take all the money but I'm like but use
it you spend it wisely and like we're
going to buy stuff I'm like ah but is it
going to be free for me through Game
Pass okay fine buy it buy it then buy
itk that's selfish part of me you good
Sol anymore a couple more super hardek
shy blade X $2 Super Chat in the words
of King Xbox fans you are not enough oh
Lord I knew that was gonna happen I knew
that was you knew that was coming there
we have dip down anime $2 superat down
Roblox banjo and pow balls I mean pow
World sh I wanted wanted to say banjo
but I felt like I would just get
attacked so I didn't say
it you're in a safe space man
you this chat is not a safe SP see you a
guess you like on a rotating door okay
stuck in the room right I would I would
I would I would cosign banjo but they
really they have to look at Mario 3D and
be like okay this is the this is the the
type of Polish we have to give banjo I
don't know if that's what they're
willing to do but I thought the game was
pretty polished I just didn't think they
changed anything enough I mean and I
know nuts and bolts is really very
different but now they needed to change
the actual formula between the two
characters but I mean modern I mean
modern Mario right you have to look at
that and be like okay how do we achieve
that and I just don't know that's what
they want to do I thought I thought I
know Nintendo was do something when they
when they did uh Mario Sunshine cuz I
love I love Mario Sunshine I thought
Mario sunsh was it was great no doubt No
Doubt Chie $5 super chat if XBox buy
Sega Cog has to play The kiru Saga
Yakuza 0o through six also pillars of
Xbox are now Cod Minecraft and Candy
Crush he's not wrong yeah a not wrong
about Candy Crush it's going to be real
now I played nin gayen and infinite
wealth so I'm caught up and like I'm not
playing anything else yeah I like the
new system I like the turn base I like
that's what I
like we have Jessie Darby $2 Super Chat
my pillars keep that boot on a
neck that's my
guy yeah get a line
Soldier and we knew it was only a matter
of time here we go let's play with each
other's joysticks $5 Super Chat had no
interest in playing po World until I
heard that we would be playing with our
Pal's balls oh man stop my pal can we
Co-op and play with pow ball
you miss yo you missed a Super Chat that
was for you and uh it says something
about I don't miss anything what I miss
you you and play with each other's
joystick and they know the name of your
your show now what pause pause that
joint was there it was there I saw it
pause time let's keep let's keep moving
was did we read Steve Hodge on lunch so
I had to pop in after seeing the T show
got that you got read that we got it we
got um Okay so we have again once again
thank you for your
patronage thank you Joy thank you thank
you for thirsting
on thank you for your thirstiness the
bank the bank thanks you respectful
thirstiness thanks you I'm not even I'm
not even shav I know you even shav you
even got
a jie gamer $20 Super Chat nobody was
out here saying they wanted competition
with PlayStation was out here buying up
every third party exclusive they could
they could find so I say Let There Be
competition however they compete
PlayStation doesn't get to set the rules
that is my
lieutenant Xbox line ever the balance
takes
soate yes this sagging
nut sagging nut sack once again five
pound Super Chat
gravity shout out to gravity yeah
gravity doing his thing yes going off
topic here k what happened to uh Wilder
against Parker and do you still think he
can beat
Joshua okay Wilder against
Parker he I don't know what the hell he
was doing he was trying to box and it
didn't look right and he wasn't himself
he's on some cool spiritual nature I I
don't like Fighters changing their
nature trying to be a boxer if you're a
puncher be a puncher um and AJ looks
good right now but we didn't see AJ get
touched on his chin so we already know
how he do leaves the building as soon as
they get hit on the chin everything his
legs go he looks great in theory until
he gets touched so we know Wilder gets
touched he's still there he looks wobbly
too but he we know that Wilder will
touch him so let's see the fight but I I
want you to stick around because I know
you like AJ and I'mma pick Wilder on
that I'm G see your man go to sleep in
the first continue boxing talk is
finished Chris Jones $2 Super Chat uh MJ
can't wait to see his brothers at pxs
East like
see you we'll be at PX to see you
brother can't wait Boston then we got
dip down to anime $2 Super Chat don't
play banjo throwing hands at Mario rip
Mario we have a banjo fan banjo fan
salute and then we have Dr Strange Love
yet again $2 in chat joystick better not
be messing with my sa in 2024 oh man we
having a boy is mind love quarrel in the
chat to give it up
we got JD gamer once again $2 Super Chat
pathetic for beging ponies mad they have
no games that I appreciate the
alliteration thank you thank you so much
all we all we caught up now we are
caught up first topic first topic yay
okay you see she like oh boy Mario like
oh now I know it's I'm talking about yo
shout out to py he said we we need he
said Lord the I needs HR we HR
department with this chat anyway moving
on so yeah Xbox developer Direct that's
the uh first one up look like the
announcement was made shout out to Xbox
wire the direct will be returning on
January 18th and uh yeah they said after
shortly after zenx uh online Studios
will host the all the Scrolls Online
2024 Global reveal so in reference to
the direct though they said will visit
machine games in Sweden to check in on
the Indiana Jones game
said swing by obsidian Irvin Office
Irvine office to see more about v head
to oxide oxide games Maryland to learn
more about Aura history Untold and take
a trip to Cambridge England to see Sena
Saga hellblade 2 from Ninja Theory now
they said please know Activision
Blizzard will not be there so we goingon
to get ABK stuff but later not at this
direct and then there's a little bit
there just a couple little paragraphs
for each uh game a little bit more as
far as what to expect so Indiana Jones
it said machine games the award-winning
Studio behind the recent Wolfenstein
series will reveal their upcoming
Indiana Jones games action adventure
that puts players in the leather jacket
of the legendary archaeologist and they
will showcase more than 10 minutes of
gameplay developer insights including
details about the setting and Story how
fans will actually play as Indie an
additional details from his next Globe
trotting adventure and the premiere of
the first Gameplay trailer then we got a
vow the team at obsidian share their
first Deep dive into the gameplay
experience fans can expect and their
upcoming fantasy action RPG set in the
Fantastical vibrant living lands learn
more about how obsidian expertise in
building worlds with deep themes Dynamic
gameplay and thoughtful reactivity come
to life in a vow where players will have
agency to make choices to shape every
step of their adventure and we got R
history Untold here from oxide games the
studios behind the veterans creative
classic strategy civilization 5 as as
they unfail exclusive gameplay share
more details about the inspiration
features and road ahead and then last
but not least sen was Saga hellblade 2
ninja der takes us behind the scenes at
their studio in Cambridge give us
Insight on how they are crafting
hellblade 2 the team will speak to the
ambition and meticulous care involved in
creating sena's journey of survival so
big drop start of the Year Xbox lot of
information lot of games setting off let
start with our esteemed guest lady Mari
what is exciting you the most about the
direct and any specific game in
particular that has your attention um I
mean let's start with the top let start
with Indiana
Jones I I mean okay so oh okay I've got
thoughts
okay let's go I'm excited and I'm also
like uh interested to see what the uh
direction is this is going to be like a
just a brain dump and then you can ask a
question I get the bars off get your
bars off let's go um I okay so I think U
Todd Howard being a very big fan great
um I I think honestly him being part of
this and I think he's eping the new um
Fallout series on coming on Amazon
there's a lot of weight on this man's
shoulders yes there's a lot of emotional
baggage that I'm resting on this man's
shoulders to get things right so uh so
so that's a big thing um I think it'll
be interesting to see because you know
the contemporaries from Indiana Jones
the movies um is Uncharted in Tomb
Raider we've seen this genre and so I I
feel like how are they going to
differentiate themselves as its
predecessor um and and being fresh about
it you know like I feel like so much of
the humor that we loved about Indiana
Jones was taken into Uncharted and and I
feel like like a classic quip that that
um Indiana Jones said right where he's
like I don't know I'm just making this
up as I go like that sounds like a
Nathan Drake um thing so I I'm
interested to see if they're going to be
able to break away from sort of the mold
that they made already in order to
differentiate themselves from their
contemporaries that we already very very
like vividly know um and I really I
don't know correct me if I'm wrong I
haven't seen anything but do we know
like the age range of of India we want
to know if you getting old
Harrison the age range of she said it
nicely she said it nicely I don't think
we're GNA get like right now Indie you
know like what the dial of Destiny Indie
I know we're not going to get dial
ofy which would be funny but I hope that
he's like you know the mid 4S Indie I
hope they're not going to Tom Holland it
with like a young Nathan
Drake and this is just full disclos this
is just a selfish ask you know as I get
older it is getting less age appropriate
for me to be horn on the 20 olds you
know and so I just I just need him to be
mid 40s Indie mid 40s
in I respect that I respect that you put
it out there for for your own wellbeing
for your own for for your piece of I
think it also like lends to his
character he's like grumpy for a reason
he's had like a lifetime of experience
he's got that sort of Mark Marin like
old man yelling at the sky sort of
energy and I I can't believe it when
it's a 20y old who's like you know who's
going through being grumpy a 20-year-old
doesn't get to be grumpy but a
40-year-old gets to be I'm sorry it's
ages age appropriate put some put some
seasoning on them season she want she
want that seasoning that mature head
give me no
unbaked I don't need an origin story you
know I don't need an origin story of
Indy I just I I want him to be the
college professor I don't okay but you
want him in that pocket I see a college
professor
honestly who it's outside we she outside
with listen she
fits she fits I respect it I respect it
your want real she fits she fits that's
it that's it I I guess I didn't really
think about to this moment where he's
like he's a college professor but all of
his adventures are only on weekends
where it's just like we can have this
adventure but I got to be back by Monday
got I got to grade these
papers imagine imagine I can't they use
that for a lot of the scripts where he's
like I should be home grading papers
right now I can't with y'all right now
like how often is he calling sick he's
like oh yeah got another she Wass the
logistics of it yeah it sounds like
there's a lot of people speaking
Egyptian should be high dude he's
like it's National Geographic got to go
got to go no doubt no doubt dip down
says ashs for Indie a Puerto Rican Indie
would be
amazing what's up
papy don't do that don't do that verion
don't do the sou version of the th son
we can't do that I I don't have
a not the bar oh got theid I can't I
can't I feel like I'm in the bodega
right now this is not a this is not a
goal we GNA move
on we're not g to do that so um so we
got that so we see where Mar's at with
that let get addict there um what about
you man what what's got you most excited
about this direct what's what's the game
you looking forward to the most where
you at with this man I kind I definitely
want to see exactly where they're going
to go in terms of what's what I'm
looking for in terms of the perspective
that you're going to be playing the game
like for instance I don't know if
they're going to go like a third person
or first person and I think that's like
really important uh so I'm kind of
curious both that's a good question he
said he both doing both he said both he
said both so maybe for I don't know
certain exploration things if the
exploration is in depth maybe you go you
know first person there um also driving
sequences and stuff like that I don't
know like that that's what worries me as
well so listening cyber Punk they got
both yeah that's machine games
adct yeah so you know that's that's the
biggest criticism I have I'm kind of
curious if you know how they're going to
handle that because if they do both how
they do them both like that how they
Implement that's not something that
people do all the time so I'm like kind
of curious like if you're going to do
both how are you doing both because that
that you you might have just uh you know
might might have found like one of the
wonders of life if you find out how to
do first person and third person and it
seems you know valuable in doing it you
know I also want to see a vow a vow is a
is is a very you know game that I've
been looking forward to for a while so
I'm curious on that um don't really care
about hellblade I'm gonna be real with
you wow that s it with disrespect it's
not disrespect I just don't
care yeah I I'm more looking forward to
a vow and what they show Indiana I don't
even know if I'm going to play Indiana
Jones it's just so this is all about a
vow for you this is just V showe the
entire thing I actually was uh you know
if you look at the reactions when we
reacted to last year's Xbox Live Well no
I wasn't part of that but like AOW is
when you know I started losing my stuff
and so was it with Fable that's
like I know stuff like hellblade's
important and Indiana Jones important
but those games don't really appeal to
me as much now I'll probably try them
out probably play Indiana Jones more
than hellblade wow but I don't know if
I'll really gravitate towards those
games as much as I would like an AOW or
a fable or or outer Worlds 2 okay like
those are the games that you know you
know synergize with need DJ oros is
killing you he
said shout out to the homie DJ oros he
can hold we can hold an objective on a
Hal little infant you know then he can
talk oh that sound like a call out that
sound like you ain't doing what you
supposed to do DJ but anyway I'm he
definitely not oh he got your skill in
question but we going to move on oh s
can he shoot a
gun what got you most excited what are
you most excited for for the direct I
have to say Indie right CU Indie it it
for a couple of reasons
right Indie isn't a property that's big
right now right they tried to sort of
bring him back was it two years ago now
that last movie didn't do super well I
haven't seen it yet but I heard that for
Indie fans it was fine it's just it was
the best whatever whatever the
expectation for Indie now is whatever
it's the general consensus wasn't great
but for Indie fans I think a lot of
people liked it especially compared to
you know that last one um they trashed
on it too which is kind of czy yeah
exactly they trash on it as well so it's
like I want to see what they do with it
because it's going to be a telling thing
uh I agree with addict that I you know
this back and forth between first and
third person machine games has never
done third person so I'd be excited to
see that because again we talk about the
hashtag just one and getting that third
person action game um but then again I
want to see what are they beholden to
Harrison Ford as indie or is this a new
starting point right I feel like they
got to go Harrison Ford like he's been
Indiana Jones as long as I can remember
like it's like I I think it would be
weird if they tried to go with someone
like a different likeness like I I
really do I think they but they go if
they go mostly third person right or
first person then they don't have to
worry about that I don't want to go
mostly first person I think that I don't
either I don't either so you want you
want like an Arcane like how arcane is
doing blade which is arcan is
historically known for first person but
they saying blade they're doing in third
person so you want the third person you
see the character you see Indie 100% I
want to be able to do that and then I
want to see what it is right cuz Indie
you could make Indie a couple of
different ways if you look at the
history of Indie Games right they've had
point and click Adventures they had that
uh Emperor tomb on the OG Xbox they had
that which was a third person like
action game okay but you can do if if
you can make it into a very cinematic on
Rails type of game where you don't have
a lot of exploration yeah or you can
turn it around and turn it kind of into
Tomb Raider where there's a lot more
exploration you have all that stuff you
have Mechanics for all that stuff
including the combat which in Indie the
combat is it seems like it's a lot more
exciting than even like I know Laura
Croft they added all this combat to her
to her game and original original Tom
didn't have any of that but Indie Indie
is all about murdering
people there's a lot of there's a lot of
death going on these in the Indie movies
so I I wonder where they're taking it if
it's going to be more of an on Rails
experience kind of like a you know
Uncharted with Uncharted 4 they gave you
a little bit more sort of lateral
movement where it felt like it was a
little bit more open but for the most
part those games are very sort of
directed and and kind of linear so I I'm
interested to see what they do with that
and again it is is kind of
the people going to look at that and be
like okay what can they do with the
property right and they're going to be
like okay if it does well then they
people going to be you know more
confident in Blade even though blade is
a bunch of years down the line but again
it's telling um then a vow man a vow is
again we're not going to see Elder
Scrolls for a while yeah yeah yeah and
obsidian has proven that they can take
that formula and do what they do with
again give give the players everything
that they love about those Bethesda
games in a more condensed package with I
think better storytelling right which is
a lot of obsidian strong point is that
their storytelling is better the the the
overall the overarching M main story is
usually a lot more coherent and and and
and player choice player agency in the
writing right so I I think I think them
doing something that is kind of the the
parallel to to Elder scows is is super
exciting for a lot of people in the P
Universe too yeah that part absolutely
exactly the pillars Universe which a lot
of people love those games as well um
and then you look at um you look at
hellblade and that last look at
hellblade we finally got a look at some
combat yes I wasn't as impressed with it
as I hoped I would be because it's it
still felt heavy and it still felt like
it was going to be like very like you
know you're looking at your you look at
your opponent you can tell when they're
going to swing up you can tell when
they're going to swing down it's more
about parrying and blocking getting out
of the way it didn't feel like it was a
smooth sort of combat um because it
feels like the weapons are heavy right
so it's not you talk about the weight
more like the weight of it like the
weight of it doesn't doesn't lend itself
to this very sort of smooth combat
experience it's more like a like a like
a lumbering experience so I again we
haven't seen the final product I I hope
that it is more sort of
quick paced and and and more and deeper
than the first one because the first one
was very first one combat was simplistic
I'll give you right it was simplistic it
was it was cinematic but it was
simplistic so I really do want to see if
they took senw to the next level right
we talk about that the first one it was
like it's a small game but the
production quality was there the
production value definitely punched up
aove they Ninja Theory with the first
one so this you know is this is going to
be an a 5H hour thing that's super
beautiful or is it going to be is it
going to be more than that right
um so I'm excited to see more about that
again shout out to
ARA that that sucks so bad yeah it's a
PC release I'm sure it's going to be
great the strategy game is going to be
great um i' I've just kind of deviated
away from those games because they they
suck your soul no civilizations but
again I'm sure it's going to be
excellent um so it's exciting to see
that we're going to be finally finally
finally be able to see these games in
depth
okay um no fair you said something that
I didn't even consider I never even
thought that it wouldn't be Harrison
Ford as Indie like I could I could see a
young aied him which I I that's what I
see that would piss you
off yeah
man but it's she don't want that she
don't want
that but for he's 80 he's 80 so younger
F could be 40 right he's 80 so maybe he
could be 40 don't give me 20 okay oh you
want the young you don't want that no
she don't want that this the thing
though right no your audience it's me
she she want the professor but but you
mentioned something where it's like what
if it's just not even his likeness at
all and I started like spiraling and I'm
like you the the one thing that I could
think of that it did work was Spider-Man
you know like they didn't give us um
Toby Maguire or Andrew Garfield at the
time I think and they even changed him
again yeah guess that works as long but
then he's got the mask on for most of it
so then you're not really thinking about
it you you you have in your head whoever
you want in there like has been Harrison
Ford that's the thing but I'm sure he
costs a lot of money so the difference
grumpy he's like video games why should
I care about that difference I think the
difference between that a little bit is
like we've seen multiple Spider-Mans I
haven't really seen multile Indies
Indiana Jones young Indiana Jones you a
like that show
like to me I think it would be a mistake
if Harrison for they might try to you
know save some money on not paying
Harrison for for his likeness we don't
know I mean un unless like he's got a
contract saying that if Indiana Jones
used it has to be his likeness so I'm
sure Lucas Films already has him scanned
from you know to toe like yeah we'll
slide you a couple bucks you can have
his likeness they sent him to kajima
scanning room they got him got him down
so yeah I thought I was getting x-rays
for my
tooth they asked me to get naked in this
room his lik this y Wilding y Wilding
shout out to the fact that I forgot I
got the uh Holy Grail back here from
Indiana Jones the ho there I forgot
about that just saw it in there anyway
what's up Salute to the Holy Ground she
said anyway I got I got listen I got
that when I was in Egypt anyway that was
the flex that was the flex that was the
flex we going to let it go I literally
went and got it I that was from over
there I I took it I took it out of the
sarcophagus like he ain't G to need
it I'm using the arc as an ottoman right
now imagine that's she got like ancient
books holding up
herand just relics just chilling said
Mari wants those scans yeah she wants a
scan that's what it is so Lord King
thoughts Man Xbox developer direct front
line is moving January you know what got
you excited to most out of them games
man this is the most terrifying direct
ever why so all right um because this
direct sets up exactly what we're gonna
get for the
he okay so if you if if you can come up
Snake Eyes this sound like mustard heart
talk this don't sound like don't sound
like we we advanced in the line listen
listen to me I'm not feeling okay this
is going this with trepidation because
we don't know what Indie is everybody's
talking about Indie but you don't know
if it's first person third person don't
whatever the hell we don't know if it's
isometric we don't know what you don't
even know if it's Indiana Jones you
don't even know if it's face so so that
part right there is scary within itself
like and I told people going into this
are you that game you tempering
expectations no hell no I don't don't I
don't feel the line is advancing right
now just just relax let me do let you my
fault I'm interruped my fault let me let
me let you c yeah let me let you cook go
ahead let let me craft this
here so all right so that that one is
the Enigma that that's the that's the
scary one that's the one that's the
unknown okay right um hellblade is the
most known but it's the most known for
the wrong reasons right it's the most
known for the last game and what we want
them to fix okay so it's like you you
won't know that until you have the game
in your hand to be honest with you
because whatever you see on the screen
is not going to translate into you
controlling the game okay so maybe they
can do a couple of things different
graphically we already knew it was
Superior graphically before when it was
uh funded with less money now that they
have more money it looks like how it's
supposed to look from them all right so
we know that part so that's the known
quantity but the unknown quantity is how
it actually feels okay how it actually
plays what really happens there Arya
nobody's talking about it and it's only
because that genre is very Niche and
that's not like the bell of the ball and
I believe they threw that one in there
um because they're going to Shadow drop
South for midnight oh we get oh I was I
was going to ask y if you think we
getting Shadow yeah they're gonna get a
shadow drop of South for midnight that
day
okay a
valve go valve what we doing that's the
heavy hitter oh so that's the one for
you that's the heavy hitter that's the
one that I believe because that's the
one everybody saw before and they you
really get an understanding of it takes
you to the point where okay this
obsidian they they they do good work we
know their stories is good they track
yeah they don't miss they hit right so
we know the story is going to be good um
the graphics are good pillow of the turn
I saw people talking about it needed to
be more gritty more no I I didn't think
so I think it need it is exactly what it
needs to be
and it looks exactly what it's supposed
to look like we just want to know how
does the magic weave with the sword play
and the actual stories that we're going
to so I know with that one we have more
confidence with that game okay is the
less uh known quantities in the other
games that we have a little bit
trepidation with it so I believe southa
midnight drops okay to cover to cover
anything like negative thoughts I
believe the show is going to come in at
uh 8 okay we do it's going to be yeah I
think it's going to come in at 8 I think
it's going to be highly good but is
still going to be left up to the
question is walking away from that show
is how does those games feel and I don't
believe that's Indy's face at all I
don't believe so I believe they walk
away from Harrison Ford because the last
movie didn't paint him in a good light
but it was a great Indiana Jones movie
if you're a fan of the series he did get
his prize in that movie so I and I think
we all wanted Indie to always get his
prize so at the end when he's crying
he's like I'm in history that part right
there was really good and he got his
prize so I think they walk away from him
I think they're able to Branch off into
their own Direction I just don't know
what the game is all right that's where
you at I'mma jump in real quick um yeah
this is this is big you know I I like I
love that Xbox is finally at that point
where we don't have to wait for all the
way to a you know to a e3 to know what
they doing right so the lineup is is so
much to the point where they're like yo
just to let y'all know ABK ain't even
going to be a part of this we got
something separate for ABK later which I
think is dope you know what I'm saying
so you funny so for me with this I got I
can't front like Indiana Jones is the
biggest surprise because I didn't think
they would be willing to first of all I
thought that they talk about it this
year maybe like at a at a direct but to
be like yo it's here we got this amount
of game play to me you talking like oh
you ready like yeah like you ready to
launch that's that's not scary to me
that's anything this that that that to
me is that's if I'm advancing a lot
because I'm like bro like you you got
one in the tuck that you've been holding
that you you you you been keeping super
humble and quiet about but you're ready
to Showcase this this this weapon to me
so I look at that I'm like okay that's
huge that's confident we know Todd
Howard's involvement we know his
excitement for the game right he's super
passionate and I guess Lucas arts and
Disney they love the pitch right and
then this is machine games which we know
do what they do they track record is
crazy Wolfenstein BJ black they made BJ
blackwitch blackwitch a character like
to to Really you know we we know him
from way back in the days this little
wild little they also know their
assignment of killing Nazis exactly they
I didn't want to say that part but yes
yes yeah absolutely no that's what it
was so it's like I'm I'm curious to see
what I would add it though there is it's
not trepidation but it's like okay how
do you handle it you're known for first
person you know but we need to see Indie
do you do cinematic flash I mean you
know cinematic Cuts you know with
certain things is it predominantly in
third person and then certain modes of
first person like Sol was saying driving
how do you handle dis in first person oh
yeah be super dis it's it's an
interesting thing cuz some people will
push back as great might work good yeah
like as great as as great as machine
games is we know what they're known for
so that's the biggest question mark in
pertaining to an Indiana g game goad go
I
think the some certain puzzle aspects
will be first person like using the whip
for certain aspect yeah yeah maybe you
do that I don't or maybe you could
switch to first person like shooting I
mean what if they do to Starfield like
Starfield has the option no I think they
said that that it's not like Starfield I
think they've already said that you
can't flipflop back and forth like stfi
I don't think you can flipflop back and
forth that would be Todd there for
then what is Todd doing what is he here
for why are you on set yeah we got to
see I mean it is it the fact I'm just
excited because it defin to get this
much information on it definitely feel
feels like they're ready and that is a
huge I think that's coming out this year
yeah that's a huge Bard yeah to to to to
uh the Xbox's 20124 lineup this is an
unexpected gy so you got that um I'm
with I'm with addict you know team
obsidian you know the Black Rock don't
miss that's what they do you know
obviously they've changed their scope
they're not trying to do specifically
this huge open world game they trying to
tell kind of like Hub worlds kind of
really refined story um I think the only
question because I didn't have it's
always some people complain like oh I
didn't feel it was graphically as sharp
the second time aroundd to which weird
to me that issue I yeah some people some
people are on that tra like it's it's
not necessarily about the graphics they
presented to me I felt like the game
they showed to me in that first CGI
scene was going to be somewhat realistic
to what the actual game was going to be
and the two art styles weren't anywhere
close to each other so it's interesting
I I I disagree but I but to your point a
lot of people have said what you said
right and they need to see more from it
you know me I like the thing with the
sword the other hand with the
spellcasting you know the different
classes and stuff like that to me I know
the story is going to be great I'm not
really worried about um about but I will
say the thing that I am worried about is
I didn't like if you read those
paragraphs everybody else was like uh
you know gameplay Indiana Jones gameplay
of gameplay Aura hellblade sound like
we're going to go behind the scenes with
the studio and talk about you know it
felt like we're going to be there in
Iceland or something like I didn't get
the sense that like we we're going to
get game plan I'm not trying to be hard
on them it's just that CU they did
showcase it at the game awards and
finally give me my combat so I'm like
yes graphically it is the greatest
looking thing I've ever seen right the
question now just but that was with two
people on the screen that but remember
the troll in the beat the one that the
game it was where they had to troll on
the beach with all the soldiers and
she's throwing that I didn't see that
troll back again I didn't see that troll
back again I saw that troll I saw that
troll in the first trailer that was CGI
cut scenes I saw that I took what they
said on hellblade
as with that particular game they're
going to show more behind the scenes so
I think they're show what I took form of
like I see Rock in Iceland bro yeah I
don't want to see I don't think they're
doing that I think they're going to go
more behind the scenes on how the
combat's going to feature cuz I if they
did come out there just say you know
we're in Iceland you guys know that
right like
the Wardrobe that is like I want more of
the game that's what I'm they're going
to spend more on this is how the game
feels uh this is how the game plays I
think that is what they're going to do I
hope so that that's that's all because
I'm I'm being very hard on them only
because this is like a flagship to me I
think this game could really be special
why is King laughing cuz I'm looking at
s face and S is like y'all are in
trouble
you know what it is after seeing that
footage I looked at it and I'm like it
it kind of felt like I it like again it
was like I didn't see a lot of stuff
going on in the
background so I'm like I'm like okay are
they just gussying up the first one and
I don't want to be reductive right but
it just feels like they kind of keeping
that scope just up and up the Polish
yeah and upping up and if that's the
case that would be a little bit
disappointing
I know the whole story is about sen and
what she has to go through and when they
first announce it I'm like all right
they're going to turn this into an epic
right they're going to turn this into
and when you saw her right and when you
saw her when you saw her with this Army
behind her and stuff like okay they're
going to expand upon it and then based
on what we saw right it felt like that
wasn't it like so you think the scope is
small you think we got the wrong sister
you think we were supposed to get
Heavenly BL man I mean Heavenly sword
Heavenly sword Heavenly sword or or
crackhead Dante from from devil cry like
I just I'm worried that it is a much
more focused thing on her and her State
and you'll have those moments but if be
but it'll be more cinematic than actual
like so you think this is going to be
like a glorified doublea
title it's going to be AAA in production
value I I don't know that it is that in
scope and when I talk about
scope pocket said by what I saw that's
what worried me like I and again this is
me in my mind what I wanted the game to
be and maybe that's being unfair yes but
think about what the first one wasog
think about what the first one they have
a budget that had they had their own
live band with the joints budget went
into the facial expressions that's what
we not doing this Am I Wrong Am I W
wrong I'm pushing back listen
I this game all right first time we saw
it the most realistic thing we've ever
seen and they showcase the Xbox series X
like oh my God oh my God he's like yeah
that fil came out that's gameplay y'all
just to let you know this ain't this
that's the real game all right first
second time we see it troll on the beach
is the biggest Sprite I've ever seen she
throwing on she got soldiers she got a
whole team of soldiers behind the
throwing Spears we like yeah this the
game this we like yo that look like a
cinema no that's the game that's the
game that's what they tell
us okay third time but that doesn't mean
that doesn't exist within a linear path
that is oh you talking about on Rails
you talk about on Rails that's what I
mean like that's what I mean by scope
right I I don't look at it like that I
look at it when I played hellblade one
right you had these set pieces where
it's focus on her a very tight camera
and then she's moving around she's going
around I don't expect open world you
think an open world I never expected
hellblade to be that so if you're
disappointed by that I would get that
but what what what are you what are you
looking for I'm not thinking straight up
open world but like like I said about
like like the latest God of War or or
Uncharted 4 where it was like it was
linear wide where it's like it's linear
right it's generally linear but you have
space to run around you have space to
explore and stuff like that the first
one the first one kind of had that but
it was limited yeah so my thing is like
I'm looking at it I'm like okay it feels
like it's more of that to me the Polish
is is obviously in the tech right
absolutely and and what they do with
that Tech and how big they make the game
feel but at the end of the day what what
I've seen so far makes it still feel
like the like the the overarching sort
of uh thought on on what the type of
game they're making wasn't something
that that was expanded upon it greatly
like it just it took that formula and
Polished it more what do you need for
for you to feel satisfied about
expansion for me it it goes back to the
combat thing I was talking about like
the combat looked kind of the same and
heavy like it didn't feel she was
weaving the fire and they threw the and
she went fire in the first one not like
that but right it's do you glossier it's
GL no I'm I'm going to play the game and
I'm going to enjoy the game I just with
the amount of time they taken with this
game I don't they haven't grown the
studio considerably that I know of um
you don't think just feels like I just
know I know that people I know people
that like me that wanted this next level
thing and you're going to get and you're
going to and my feeling is you're going
to get next level on the Optics you're
going to get next level on the Optics
it's going to look beautiful but watch
the chaos
soend hold up real quick what I'm
getting from you is you you expect them
to level up like world just say you were
over world like I don't hold hold up
like combat is yes real quick real quick
what I'm getting from him is I think
they're going to focus too much on the
visuals of the game and not enough on
like the gameplay part of the game we
like expanding on combat expanding on
you know variety of weapon uses
expanding on the people you fight and I
while I say is we saw one clip yeah in
reference to the combat which is fair I
will say it wasn't enough to make me
think that they fair that that's fair
you y'all can be have trepidation and be
worried I'm not there I nowhere near
there like to me what the only concern I
have is different which is when are you
coming out because to me they've been
very protective of this yeah and to me
it's like you know you got something and
you want to give it a Polish so my
concern is well now that AOW is coming
here and giving 10 minutes of game play
is a vow releasing before you are you
are end of the year kind of a thing
as opposed to setting it off because a
lot of people would assume that
hellblade is going to set it off with
the first half of the year but as far as
the questions I think I think that's
fair what you're saying my main issue is
actually the F with the first one was
the puzzles were redundant you know what
I'm saying and I didn't like they they
went to that well too much with the
symbols and all that if you give me the
first game with real puzzle more serious
mechanics say visceral fighting
different enemy types different enemy
different environments I'm fine I I mean
I am totally good with that with the
most beautiful looking thing graphic but
okay visual simplistic fighting visual
simplistic fighting like the like you
don't want a little bit of a skill tree
yeah so that's my thing that's my thing
that's my thing that this is going to be
the most beautiful on Rails cinematic
experience it's going to be on Rails but
I don't I think that you're you're being
extremely harsh that the combat will not
evolve more and that it's just going to
be the dude running at you two swings
next dud running at you so that's what
you think you think that
it's they showed us they haven't proved
him wrong like we haven't seen a more
in-depth variety people you could fight
we haven't seen you know multiple
different unique skill trees or anything
like that they CU if you think about it
like throughout the years there's one
thing and one thing consistent when they
show this game is how good it looks no
that's fair that's fair I can't push
back until we see more of it so that's
all I was say fight of the mustard heart
yeah that the very mustard heart talk to
me but I you know it's cool but he look
to his point he's going off what he saw
so I gotta just my brother this is this
is how I love him so much because I can
look at his face and KN when he's not
yeah I know you can tell he wasn't
feeling me so that's fine look we you
know what it is it's just cuz you when
when they they they have control of sun
one now right and it's that thing of
like I think a lot of people thought the
same thing like oh this is their just
one this is this is their God of War
last Nathan Drake moment this is their
character what are they going to do
right so in my my mind my Hope was you
take that character and you take what
she was in that first game and you blow
it out right you really blow it out and
you make this you make this one of your
new pillars you make sure that this
character is on the box I mean it was
with the system it was with the I just
don't we'll see oh no I definitely
disagree with you they're definitely
pushing this oh they're going to push it
to the I've never seen Microsoft by but
the fact that they had a live band but
they push redf too and not like they
push no red fall don't do that don't do
me like that come on don't do me like
that no they're going to push it it's
just a matter of how it's a matter of
how the fan base reacts to it yeah fair
enough fair enough it's too soon it's
too I think if s get I got to stop
throwing sauce on he tried to instigate
he's no no I get what's go oh are we off
the subject we got an off subject okay
question about AOW um and this is
perfect because some of yall are are
bullish on it I am somebody um who has
never played any of the pillars games so
please take this with a grain of
salt um but for me I feel like with
obsidian games there's always a very
bold perspective that you can see from a
trailer whether it's the Aesthetics of
pment or kind of like the cheekiness of
like grounded I I forget when it was but
remember when they're trailer was like
for the biggest game cyber punk you know
like you kind of get the idea of what
the humor is and sort of the the flavor
and the vibe and I feel like with a vow
coming from somebody who has never
played the previous pillars um games um
I don't I don't see what the Bold sort
of like direction is other than me being
like okay it's Elder scres with like
neon Powers um Am I Wrong to feel that
way or or is there something that I
should be extracting more I I I've never
played the pillar games either but I did
a lot of research on the story like
pillar is a lot of it's about like
religion like apparently there's like
fake Gods non-fake gods and like I think
it's going to be more towards that
because uh what people says this is
before one of the falls on pillars of
Eternity uh when like one of the Gods
like got like fail From Grace or
something like that I don't know
definitely look up videos I'm kind of
curious if you're going to be the person
that defeats that God in this like I I
don't I don't know cuz you know they
haven't really explained a whole lot on
here so I'm I'm kind of curious on that
yeah no I get I get where she's coming
from that I think what it is is you're
looking for what's that that stamp that
person stand that's going to make it
stand out like we know utter worlds has
that humor and there there's certain
things that grounded has that bombastic
this and how they having fun and that
you want to know what that AOW hook and
I think it's beautiful that we get the
10 minute game play to say okay yeah we
going to get a feel of what this I
thought that was Indiana Jones gets
10-minute game playay um yeah no
actually you're right 10 minutes for um
Indiana Jones but we are getting
gameplay a gameplay experience from a uh
of our Deep dive and they talked about
player agency and player choice so that
to me their writing their strength and I
actually like that they pull their scope
back from mobile world because I feel
when they do Hub World they can tell
more detailed stor yeah really
concentrated and that is their Str cuz
they say hey that's where we are let's
get back to what we do I believe I
thought the outer worlds was incredible
yeah I think another interesting thing
is uh because pillars is so kind of in
the vein of DnD D coming off of Boulders
Gate 3 how do they do they translate
that D and D formula that Boulders gate
formula into this this first person game
right do they do it that way or do they
s do they simplify it more and is it
more of an elder strolls type game as
opposed to you know what
yeah I think it's going to be a
combination I I I think they're going to
stay away from from the uh you know the
the the core of stuff like D and D
because I this game's been development
for a while so I don't think like
Boulders gate would have had any impact
like inspiration wise on this uh but you
know there's not very many games that
function like Boulders gate like it's
not like we have like a like a long list
of games that do course you would know
because you end games before you play
because he beat the goblins K beat the
Goblins 30 minutes into the game too
soon the wound is too
[Music]
[Laughter]
soon just imagine me
just got it yeah you do it toight if you
do it look final thing I'll say is that
look overall regardless to any concerns
we all have for any particular game this
is a massive year for Xbox coming yep
bro the fact that you could potentially
get an Indiana Jones game AOW new IP
from obsidian hellblade 2 most one of
the highly anticipated games graphical
Fidelity looking games for for them Aura
and then still got ABK and other things
in the tuck like this is setting up to
be and the fact that we talking about
this now before a summer showcase which
means there's more stuff for them to
talk about is massive I'm excited I love
the fact that we get these little beats
now all throughout the year from a
marketing perspective super dope they're
starting to fire on all sellers I told
people in 2023 you know what I'm saying
strong year obviously you had the
Starfield you had a Forza you had a
high-fi rush right R for we we
remembered and then but we had a lineup
yeah we're good now right 60 frames
whatever but you know to
see yeah nobody to fight no we not going
to go there but as a as a whole for
their philosophy and putting stuff in
the game pass and having first party TR
to have that type of year now to set it
off with these type of games and we know
more is coming is massive I like they to
mention this the small third party stuff
that they have in the bag for the game
pass already we're going to get replaced
hopefully replaced Tower is still there
Tower we whatam call it um stalker
stalker we forgot about that yeah like
they've got
stuffs too they got stuff in the tuck
and to the last point I say it's King's
Point is let's remember you know last
year high five Rush was a stealth drop
South midnight right is do we get
another stealth drop King's going on you
know the south of midnight Midnight to
is another like there's a lot of stuff
they could do and I'm curious if they
keep that momentum but that's all I got
on the developer direct uh Super Chat we
swing to the next one or we got a bunch
you want to just hold on to them or yeah
let's let's let's I think they might be
relevant to whatever we was talking
about and then later on see let me see I
got to respect okay this one definitely
isn't dip down anime to Super Chat pick
one sof Strange Love or joystick save
the
world save the world from your love
interest
okay we have decran Zale member for 26
he pick though I no
he continue with the donations that's
what I appreciate you thank you for your
patronage thank you for your patronage
that's okay you I I'll take the
abuse continue Lord gold um looking
forward to 3 uh unicorn Overlord and
iudin Chronicles three straight months
of good games no ports to PlayStation
but keep improving the relationship with
Nintendo getting game pass on switch
2 okay all
right we got hi
hop he want that game pass goodness
continue we have a midnight Druid $
Super Chat been saying for a year uh and
with people arguing with me that a vow
would come out before hellblade with
think getting the Deep dive in hellblade
not so we think about his first half
like I had hoped yeah quite possible
before June yeah potentially get release
dates for all these games would be
dope then we have puckish Rogue 100 $5
Super Chat I thought a thought just hit
me what if Indie fear of snakes is part
of the game for example what if you can
can't go through a door because a snake
is in the way that would be awesome I
mean that that's something that somebody
like a super fan like like a Todd Howard
would probably try to incorporate into
something right no doubt and we have sir
xman $2 Super Chat please show new stari
DLC that would be big too I'm sure
they're going to have their own thing
for that I'm thinking they're going to
have shed space expansion all right yeah
then we have R&B AKA The Underground
gamer okay uh $5 Super Chat uh this
indie game will be the fifth movie we
deserve because that last film was a two
pack of of ARS never forget Xbox got
their show before the SE secret
PlayStation show oh man y messy my God
very messy I'll do this with my mouth
then we
have cuz he's 24 years old you got to be
40 to get the joke in the movie
bro let me see let me see we have Ru and
Rufio member for five months bronze
Indie as a linear open world game or
something in between what would you guys
like to
see I would love the open worldness
always open yeah I love what they done
always open I've Loved what they've done
with Laura Croft and for Indy to be less
than that feels a little weird but again
it's a movie maybe he sees it that way
and it's more linear I don't know I want
to feel like our Uncharted I thought
Uncharted was uh
bigger as far as like Blockbuster it
felt like Michael B Michael Bay stuff to
me yeah they you never know they could
be going for that right the I wanted to
feel like God of War 2018 like the Hub
kind of
stuff continue all right then we have
sir xman again $5 Super Chat okay it's
official this young lady needs to be
added to your show she matches perfectly
with every one of you guys personality
King am I right they do acquisition I
said she fit she F acquisition talk with
the Lords
already they want us to sign up all
right we got the
table send over the
contracts no then we have uh L shimazaki
with the thousand yen Super Chat you
guys think Indie fits as being first
person it's going to be tough sell for
some for some it may be absolutely I can
see I can see the the whip in one hand
and the gun in the other I can see it
see it and again I prefer
100% I need to see I need to see Indy
she need to see 40y old 40y old IND
specific she wants to be able to at
least switch back and what now if it's a
20-year-old India UK first person you
don't have to oh she's like we don't
want to see him that's not her real
answer she's
just's mess it's kind of my real answer
mari's messy she's like they bring that
Tom holl I cutcenes just she wants to
see Indie with with a firm rear
pause no she don't no she don't move it
on you're kind of
loose
yeah got to go start doing them squats
again oh some burpees
heyo oh man time time then we got slowmo
backs slap $10 Super Chat Tomb Raider
and Uncharted took inspiration from
Indiana Jones because it was a
successful formula on a character and
plot it makes sense to take inspiration
from those IP which had successful game
design too yeah the same thing but they
they took inspiration from like the
essence of Indie not really game play I
about to say what Indiana Jones game you
talking about the closest the closest
one is not even remotely Harry yeah
right it's the emperor tomb game the
emperor tomb game is a third person
action game but but that game I mean
it's so old that again you can see the
the skeleton of it but not really um
then we got dip down anime2 Super Chat
time for the new new one old Indie go
watch
VHS y m facts facts salute then we have
uh Tim allcoin Tim allcoin screenwriter
shout out to Tim with the $2 Super Chat
opinions on Direct games coming uh 2024
plus what
order oh order oh of the order of they
of which they're coming out I I I'm I'm
a FV for whoever's in red for order I
think I see a vow
first and then hellblade so so then AOW
is in red Falls order I see it I see
hellblade first then Indiana uh then AOW
and then uh Indiana follow could be that
too
based on the paragraphs in the thing I'm
going to say V first Indie is like the
summer little Blockbuster and Hell blade
maybe wait for the end of the year like
that November you know winter smash
that's why I'm and nobody said already
that's interesting no one said coming
out because there a PC drop it's a PC
drop top yeah top of the Year Mari um
any what you think the order is um I
think hell blade I think it's the most
done I think out of the three um I agree
with you for the rest of it Cog I think
it's a summer drop for Indie I don't
think he's a Christmas feel um and I
think a I think it's probably going to
be more of like the Christmas drop so
that so that everyone's home I respect
that yep and I do like a vow separate
from hellblade I want them to breede
from each other I don't want them like
to next to each other release days so I
like I like where you at with that what
else we got saw uh we
got yeah we do uh we have bad
programming with the super chat if Indie
goes to Chronicles of Ric route it can
work in first and third person I forgot
about remember Chronicles of R Ric was
amazing yeah but but Ric was amazing but
it wasn't OG Xbox game it's like you
know you your thoughts on what makes a
great game today have evolved so it's
like you give me just give me that and
it's like ah just just like when you
pick up a old Genesis controller yeah
controllers evolved yes I mean going
back to a was saying about being
grateful about these drops you know it
is not that long ago when games look
like you know you're like I played
that not been that long so lot to be
grateful for for how far games have come
and like oh my God look at the stuff
that we get to play it's insane actually
in a short period of time too yeah my
parents don't they they they don't care
about other games at all but they will
look at something and be like that's
what it looks like now I'm like yeah
that's what it looks like now and that's
not to mention like you know we we got
Final Fantasy rebirth coming up here
soon like that's not even mentioning
third
party yeah there's a lot what else all
right then we have Donald taku $10 Super
Chat just to back up just to back up sof
remember that one of the first Diaries
Ninja Theory put out hyped up the combat
by training the actress and called it
the most ambitious SL realistic I know
tell them I know tell them it doesn't
look like that though tell that's all
right that's all right Don don't worry
about don't never mind the facts Don
taco right I know I know he said never
mind the facts I want to know the facts
that you're referring to I know I know
Don did his homework though I salute the
Don no he ends with it doesn't look like
that though that's what he ends with
that I'm ignoring that part I want let
me paint my narrative let me paint my
narrative and I I I'm acknowledging the
first know you know your truth you know
your trth then we have Jay rber $5 Super
Chat y'all notice that now now that
PlayStation is struggling with games and
Microsoft now has ABK people are
clamoring for Xbox to put games on
PlayStation messy now they want us to go
third party but
sorry five biscuits for everyone
messy there we have puckish Rogue 100 $2
Super Chat yo Cog they dropped the
Tekken 8 opening mov I know got to go
see I heard Yeah Eddie Eddie Gordo is
going to be DLC
his coming Leroy I'm going to main Leroy
post yeah yeah the grandm of drip
continue then we have Matt $2 Super Chat
lady Mari would be a perfect addition to
I they they got their
acquisition yeah they got their
acquisition papers ready I was talking
to King once and King said something
about yeah addex the Grand Master or
something I was like whoa whoa I'm not
the
grandm I I was with I was with my son I
was like adct the grandm something he's
like I'm not the grandm careful that
verbage you're right right the verbage
keep careful with the verbage it would
be it would be something else we going
to move on so we don't get demonetized
we going to move on that's dangerous
that's dangerous especially for
addicts we're talking about we're
talking about fantasy games here fantasy
BR wizard plenty of wizards are not
doing this song No Grand Masters or
grand Wizards we going to move on we're
not doing this to my man add it continue
we have the legendary Yi $5 Super Chat H
let me see Mari this can't be your last
time in il you definitely got to come
back you rock dude
[Music]
AB love I love it then we have Jesse
derby2 Super Chat Kong will die yes he
will this is an inside joke where where
King calls PlayStation Kong and he wants
them to die okay inside
continue then we have JD gamer $2 Super
Chat pathetic Port begging ponies can't
have Xbox yo get your B get your
soldiers in line bro n they doing what
they're supposed to do Xbox propaganda
in full effect it's the first time jayd
is Super CH us wow Jay do is in the chat
got J
Dub you're going to get this work Jay
I'm telling you now let's see not
talking about the Xbox whole slate
coming to Playstation I knew it that
line is folding salute K kid get your V
hey Jay you gonna come to the show on
Thursday
oh I'm be real work out well for you
last remember the last remember the last
to advance the line to the stream
remember remember the last couple of
times you showed up around
me actually actually you know what are
you implying going be a good situation
for J to show we got to thank jdub we
got to thank jdub because he was on that
show there was so many people that made
montages off of that man's face that we
grew out leave leave the homie alone
salute to the homie man I love hey J I
love you man show up on
Thursday you you my Lucky Rabbit you're
invited to the live stream Jay du if
you're available is what king is say you
you can make the argument if it wasn't
for Jay du the backto back thing never
had so
so many people clipped IOP for the live
all right we got to move on we got to
move your SL we got Sanchez sanchz
gaming $5 Super Chat PSA uh Playstation
has no games and Mari is the
goat we got J again $5 Super Chat I'll
be there I want to see what I'll be
playing on my PlayStation 5 tell them
about your secret Xbox account oh man J
I know what you be playing on
PlayStation that baby steps oh
man how's the hell divers
though oh that's coming soon yeah true
oh we got J JD one more time $2 Super
Chat D du Port JD du Port begging and
can't have Xbox games and then we have
Jesse Derby again to Super Chat we got
these Port Beggars here
Jesus behave we have company so we we
all set we caught up as one thing I want
to mention I'm sorry to bring down the
mood a little bit but we forgot to
mentioned it at the top of the show uh
send out some love to our brother
Christopher
Hart passed away yesterday send your
love to him Christopher hardt is always
in here joking with everybody you know
you know goes harder that he reps that
PlayStation hard but it's always love in
here so that's our
brother he's going do something real
right now real serious Yeah man so much
love and I see I saw the picture we were
wondering why we hadn't seen seen him in
a while yeah now we see it send some
love to to man Christoph
heart okay we got uh let me see J G one
more time okay bring up the spirits $2
super CH Mario you have to come back to
the IL Dam they trying to get their
acquisition people I paid off I'm like
say nice things to me you know in the
chat your fair Bas
is you're the final piece we need at all
it is we we need a pink ranger
I why she got to be a pink ranger I'm
cross between the pink and yellow ranger
let's just it is we know she can't be
the Green Ranger what he did he's bad oh
man soon too soon too soon too soon W
what's up we caught up all uh yes sir
we're caught up all right this is
addict's topic uh Halo TV
series season two trailer announced
attic has thoughts oh yeah I have
thoughts and I want people's opinions on
this I don't know how big of a fan were
you Mari of the Halo TV series the first
season uh Curious and what we've seen on
going into the second season there was
some statements from like pretty popular
people in like the the Hollywood
industry that was talking about it too
you know justifying or you know uh
attacking the fact that the mask is if
that's required or not can he show
emotion with the mask I like I can't
remember someone and I'm sure someone in
the chat can uh find it but someone
tweeted and said yeah cuz uh you know
Darth Vader had a whole L had a hard
time showing emotion with this and and
it showed the scene where the emperor
was electrocuting him he said if we only
knew it was shout out to our homie
Stephen Ford he said if we only knew
what Vader was feeling in this moment
but we can't he's got to help it he was
happy right he was elated he he was
elated being
electrocuted I don't think I've ever
heard Vader laugh so I wonder what that
would sound like in his mask if he was
chuckling at that
moment um I will admit I only saw two
episodes of the HALO Series was that two
episodes too many oh man
honestly I I wish that I think it wasn't
like I I wish it was front loaded with a
lot more like I feel like the first two
episodes should have been the last two
episodes of the season um I it it was
all it was kind of like opened up with
like oh Master Chief doesn't know who he
is he's having an existential crisis you
know like I'm finding myself oh
everything's I'm like can we establish
what the Baseline is first before we get
there you know it's like it's a little
bit too fast too soon because because
even though I know who Master Chief is I
don't know who he is in this context and
I'm like give it to me from the
beginning who are we you know what are
ideals so that when he does rip away
from that ideal and goes oh I want my
own little grou and I got to save this
kid um you know like why is that
different has he done this a hundred
times like this before is he always
saving kids you know like like I don't
want him to spell out like I don't know
why I did it I like saying I don't know
a 100 times it didn't really do it for
me um uh I think I was kind of confused
by the World building at some points I
felt like it it didn't read Halo to me
it read a little bit more um like Fifth
Element you know there were some like
wacky costuming and some like just moods
that weren't right for me um you like
when they brought Lady Gaga on and he
was like oh
yeah hey hey Mari how' you how do you
feel when he when Master Chief was in
the the Lawless civilization not having
his helmet on
I first I wondered would this have
happened if Mandalorian wasn't a
thing yeah I was like I was like did
they write the HALO Series and then
they're like all right we did it guys we
did it boys and girls let's let's print
it on paper and then the Mandalorian
came by and they're like [__] it's the
Sor I SW I'm like they're like it's the
same
story so well how are we going to
differentiate ourselves we can't get rid
of the one piece where it's giving him
emotion and humanlike qualities of
wanting to save uh a you know a helpless
being grou or Quan ha um and it's like
all right then let's unmask him um
because clearly that's the one
differentiator and then we all went why
that was supposed to be
me and another thing that like when H
girl had had the gun and he's like it's
not hit me it's good this is a mark hel
and then and then he takes it off oh now
she can hit you that makes a lot of
sense my dude yeah I hated that scene I
know exactly what you're talking about
yep I hated that scene I I wanted him to
build he he takes it off because she's
like how can I trust you and and then he
takes the the the helmet off and I'm
like that says everything wrong about
Chief right because oh she cooking go
ahead it's built on a legacy of trusting
this character by not seeing him as a
human being his human face it's having
built that trust over years and years of
playing his games um with him as the
tial character and and it has everything
to do with what's in his heart and not
what the the me you know like the
menacing sort of like thing that we look
at from the outside if anything we come
to trust the menacing thing that come
that that we see on the outside so in
order for her to not trust that rips
away everything that's thats built and
not to mention like we say master chief
had enough like thought process enough
intuition that okay I'm just going to
take my helmet off and she's not going
to shoot
me doesn't seem Master Chief yeah like
why did she earn that like but anyway
but it's my turn I'll get it I I do want
to add one thing to what Mari is talking
about what ad is talking about and this
is the push back this is where In
fairness to the other side that CU
obviously we are team the other side
obviously we are team keep your damn
helmet on right it's not even team keep
your helmet on team like have your
helmet on on situations that make sense
he be having his helmet off everywhere
like I'd be surprised if he had his
helmet off in space can't bre they let
be know with the poster the poster they
got his face just in case you thought
it' be
different they they be super rebellious
with the poster they like you don't like
that so what we still going so so
respectfully that they going there might
to just get rid of the the the helmet at
this point exactly like he they got him
shooting in the civvies you see where
he's in the civvies shooting with with
no armor no armor see that that's my
issue is okay if you want to build this
emotional thing that's fine but
logically from the from the from the
person we know as Master Chief in the
Hal LA and I love the people that said
this is their interpretation well their
inter interpretation sucks like
logically from what we've known of
Master Chief throughout the years has
Tech he's a tactician he's a he's very
strategic he's he's he's extremely like
intuitional when it comes to the combat
you mean to tell me he going to fight
with no helmet on just out like that
like that makes no sense I'm with you in
fan the other side I just want
especially when the covenants got
jackles anytime you just get sniped
facts now if this is what they say this
is Pablo sh his IGN article who plays
massach Chief he said um why explain why
massach Chief doesn't always wear his
helmet he said you're not going to be
able to bring an audience along long
form story without having access to the
character's face which tells you what
they're feeling how they think about
everything the access to a character's
emotional life over the course of time
is what makes you empathize and connect
with the character he said I'm sorry but
having the mask off is is the only
choice for long form storytelling and
television and my contract says as much
what I would say to anybody who dis pasc
Pablo going in Pablo going in y'all he
said I want to say to anybody who
disagrees with that I respect that
opinion but it's a pretty basic place to
start when you're talking about a
television show of quality and the last
thing he says one thing I've learned
early early on is that as many different
opinions in the Halo Universe as there
are Halo fans so obviously you're not
going to be able to please everyone but
I want to say that we are tailoring
tailoring an entertainment experience
that's tailored to the medium that it's
for so he pushing back hard y go get
this face and he get it's fine because
at the end of the day I got one thing
Last of Us St to lore and made it make
sense like it just I get it people's
like oh it's hard to show emotion there
is V for vanana uh multiple people
that's had a mask on the entire duration
of their game we were just talking about
Darth Vader obviously they're not the
same one to one but don't get me this
you can't show emotion with that I see
face out too you can see emotion emotion
on like Final Fantasy Tactics where
there's there's little Sprites walking
around a mat so you mean to tell me that
they could show emotion and that with no
words just text and some Sprites walking
around the map but they can't do it I
was in my previous comment I have a
feeling they have not seen the
Mandalorian but don't say already gon
say you can't compare it they push back
at us they get
mad I think the double whammy for Halo
fans is like we have come to know Master
Chief's voice so well I and trust that
voice that it's like it's it's all of a
sudden saying that the voice is not good
enough right like that we need human
eyebrows and eyeballs to to evoke
emotion when when Halo made us cry
from
just go ahead I was going to say like I
saw some people sharing this on Twitter
perfect example uh in Halo infinite when
he was talking to the pilot after the
pilot was you know really down on
himself for abandoning everyone he had a
logical conversation never took his mask
off and there was there was more emotion
in that scene than there was all of the
TV show yeah I think there's something
to say about a mask too it's I think
that okay we're gonna get we're gonna
get real deep now like we all wear masks
right in our in our day-to-day lives
like different masks for different
situations type of thing and I think we
do that because it emotionally Keeps Us
guarded that way and I think that a
character that keeps his mask on at all
times there is
something that that em evokes emotion
without saying anything at all there is
a inability to open up there's an
inability to say the things that you you
wish that you could say with a with a
facial expression that you keep hidden
behind this mask and I think that's what
makes it compelling you you know that
he's going through all of these things
and just the the the the motion of an of
a face going here can say a lot more
than a face
going you know it's
like it's subtlety and I think that that
rather it's the analogy of you feel more
when somebody is teary eyed and trying
to get their emotions out than somebody
who's balling and having a crazy cry you
know it's and and I think that we've
lost that
subtlety no fair enough fair enough uh
solve uh your thoughts so like Mari I
think I watched two or three episodes of
the first season I think I stopped when
when he met when he met cortan when I
stopped I actually felt like the show
got a little he said when it got
good I actually felt like the show got a
little bit better when it come to yeah
CU it felt like it felt like the
relationship was a little bit
antagonistic at oh yeah first didn't
want her at all thing in his head what
the hell was this thing so yeah I got to
go back and finish it but um after
seeing the trailer right yes I
completely agree about the about the
helmet thing it just it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense you it can be done it
has been done I think it would Elevate
the quality of the show having to you
know figure that out and how to you know
extract emotion from an emotionless
helmet but we like like Mari said I've
cried at many a Halo moment and I'm just
like no it can be done it can absolutely
be done so yeah that's sad that they
going that route I understand that it is
his own thing and and they need to
appeal it have it appeal to a broader
audience which is why these decisions
are made but n i i i to me that's what I
liked kind of about the the second
trailer right even though yes it is it
is Lady Gaga talking over the trailer
about she's gonna bring your ruin at the
end of the
dayen the Fall Of Reach I if they handle
a Fall Of Reach properly if they handle
the Fall Of Reach properly I'll be happy
all right I I'll be happy if at least
those lore points are handled with the
care that they deserve um so I'm excited
to see how they've evolved a little bit
and maybe listen they could they could
push back all they want they have to
listen to the criticism you know how bad
it will be if they mess up the Fall Of
Reach yeah that would be that would that
would if they mess up the Fall Of
Reach cuz cuz people are very when it
comes to Halo when it comes to lorewise
like the Halo lore heads like the reach
is like the
Pinnacle I got a break protocol Jason
Hendrick find he said during the random
love seen Chief will put the helmet
on yo you wow for that
[Music]
continue yeah yeah yeah Master cheeks in
fact the master Cheeks is out there
Master cheeks clapping cheeks clapping
president of War he felt that was the
thing to do I I'm I'm I'm hopeful for
what they could do with all of reach but
again when you think about it I and I
don't know I don't know the interstitial
stuff with the books yeah when you think
about it how much is Chief actually
involved in that right so you know do
they Midway Point through the season is
Chief just out of the picture and
they're focusing on uh I forgot the team
name of the team um that would be
interesting right to S Swit shift the
focus from Chief and focus on this team
and really really go you know follow and
suit with with the story I wonder if
Noble sex is going to be on know that's
what I'm talking about yeah
Noble yeah that would be that would be
something right and Noble Six obviously
never takes off the helmet and you don't
know who it is yo you know how be crazy
if noble 6 is in it and he's the only
one that don't take his Mas I'm done I'm
done they say if Nate fillian is going
to be in it is he going to be part of
the team or is he not going to I don't
know if they got that that's a budget is
going yeah I know about that I don't
know about that bag I don't know about
what do you think of the people that say
this isn't the game you don't it's
unrealistic to expect a game you know
the lore from the game and this is it
own thing they're they're you it's
adaptation they're doing their own thing
and if you want the game just go play
the game like what do you guys think of
that comments because there's a lot of
them and you got n we got one sitting
right here
they like I said I understand the whole
thing about you having to make it for a
broader audience I understand that and
in that there will be changes but I just
still think also like you said about the
Last of Us The Last of Us stuck pretty
closely to that and they they they
filled in the gaps right for some things
that works for TV and I think they they
could have taken that same approach with
this and just fill in the gaps and give
us you know and just give us what what
we wanted yeah again I think the biggest
point is the hel because you stopped at
three I stopped the three so I I can't
really say but
okay point it might have been three
episodes too many for me at that point
Mari um I think that it really depends
on um franchises and there's too many
good examples out there to mess this up
at this point you know like I think last
of us is a great one where Sonic did a
good job yeah they realize they realize
where um the fans are fervent for lore
and I think you can't you can't deviate
from the lore that we know and the
things that we like for certain aspects
detective Pikachu is a fantastic idea of
like do whatever you want man like we
have an idea of what this might be and
then do whatever you want you're not
touching a thing that like a hot you
know like like a
scar but something like Halo something
like last of us something that that has
evoked emotion I think that is the thing
that you can't touch to much cuz it it
is it's deep rooted in uh players and
it's like I don't know I I think I saw
Witcher in the in the comment section
but like Witcher is something where I
didn't I'm not emotionally tied to it I
I put you know like 500 hours but I'm
not like oh my God my girl has to be
yeah to be here here's my thing like I
understand people like they're trying to
BR to a bigger audience but it's just
like people in the chat are saying you
got Last of Us those mad successful
uh you know the Mario movie made like a
billion dollars like Sonic's they're up
to the third one like you can still have
lore and still be accurate to the lore
there's a difference between having be
lore accurate and then the characters
don't even act like the characters from
the game like there's difference between
the two and I I feel like people are
like oh you know I honestly truly feel
that they could have did anything to
this and that you could use that excuse
for everything it's an annotation addict
like you don't you don't need stick with
the Lord Temptation like come
on let me get K I want to get it start
real quick on this uh the turning off my
mic the
trailer oh man I loved it okay I loved
it only thing I didn't love about uh
season one was Master cheeks that's it
y'all didn't need to have my man butt
cheeks out that was it that that you
know what's quick
call okay okay what
happen no I'm talking after this though
okay knock yourself out it's your topic
but my thing is we had this conversation
last year we had it and for all y'all
grumpy dudes get off my lwn put your
helmet on you
deviant dud out here talking that much
season two showed up and it did well
yeah it did fantastic despite what you
thought and then and then they said yo
for my next
trick y yall like yall like Mas off you
ain't like you ain't like the mask off
this time I'm taking my jacket
off I'm busting shots in the street with
a tank top on
Yo the chief of the C I'm not g to lie
I'm the worst thing that can do now is
have him lose all his armor and out
there with just a
gun and and it was still selling we get
a season
three for all the people that think they
know how TV
work this ain't games all right and and
listen if y'all mad at anybody be mad at
uh Pedro Pascal be mad at him that
Mandalorian
crap and then he he has infected
everyone else all right so this it is
what it is if you don't like it do like
everybody else and stop at episode three
but if you like myself that like Star
Trek Star Wars TV shows that are uh
different this is a to me this is a
comic book drawn by not the main artist
and not the main story to me I got you
and I just go in and I just watch it and
have fun now apparently millions of
other people felt the same way M and
we're on our way to season 2 and I'm
going to watch every episode like I
watched it the first one I watched every
episode and then after we finish here
I'm going to rate it high on Rotten
Tomatoes again oh my Lord and then we
gonna go on to season 3 where he's going
to have a jetpack with no
armor okay you're the one on Rotten
Tomatoes got it we found them we found
him we found where he at yeah we know
who it is explain something to me yes
please how's King going to talk about
this lore this lore that you know it's
just for fun and he's the same person
that be nitpicking every comic book
movie because it don't stick to law when
they don't stick to the law in MCU oh
going let us know oh that's you don't
like H Jack because he ain't the same oh
facts get him get him I can't stand Hugh
Jackman see oh he to he Too Tall he too
tall for Wolverine
yeah yeah my my hate a Hugh Jackman
ain't stopp him from being the D Jackman
don't wear the suit was King was
protesting he had his picky face he
hates me he hates me Jackson hates me
and you know what's the best part about
it he's back playing
Wolverine and and he's not GNA have that
damn mask on yeah they respect the law
King let them let Wolverine do them my
get off the law just enjoy it it's just
for fun but you know what I did I
watched and I'm gonna watch so I got no
Choice I'm not there telling him put on
your damn ass you but it's not going to
happen so again I'm in a position where
either I can be on for the ride or I can
just do like y'all did and say I'm GNA
watch two or three episodes he went from
one side of neutral real fast I respect
it he standing on it he standing on it I
can't stand it I'm I'mma keep it real
but at the same time Dan says y'all
forget King admits He's a
hypocrite y'all got to understand that
y'all not going to box me in baby we not
box you we fa look y y'all said all the
points I really needed to say um look to
to regardless of my feelings of hating
the mass situation and my feelings of
them being
overtly aggressive with we're going to
continue this and we know you don't like
it but we're continuing this you know my
whole thing is obviously reach is an
important thing I will say this the part
I did like was actually the end when
Cortana took him over when he had to
shut up and wear the Mas yeah well hey
you got catch up there's a there's a
segment where it happens and when that
happens wherever that was in season one
I enjoyed I was like yes this is a shut
up and
dribble get in there and do what I like
and and bring the action to it so I was
fine with that but yeah we'll see we got
to see how they do you know the whole
auor situation and whatever and shout
out to my man K Santi reprising his role
as
um my man is in there doing his thing
you thought I wasn't going to get you
I'm going get you brother I saw you in
there you know saying it's good to see
you back and we'll see what happens but
my tempering my expectations based on
the
showrunners
got I got way more excited when I saw it
at reach that's all I was going to say
that's true what do you think they would
would have happened if they just went
full mask on didn't really say anything
about it but season 2 came board and
they're like full mask on do you think
that fans would come back to it or do
you think fans would just be like a
little too late I they would they would
they complain but they would they come
back here's the thing Mari like I don't
mind his masks off I just want it to
make sense from like him being in battle
like he'd just be walking around
literally just sh shots being fired
around mask off like I didn't like it
when he was walking around without his
armor on and he had like the the the
onesie on the onesie had the yes we was
walking around with in host the hosle
area and he got nothing on and everybody
know it's Master Chief he he could be
merked at any minute and I'm like it's
too heavy for him he's a super soldier
and he it's too like he's like oh it
gets hot sometimes I didn't like see it
it looked like it felt like I was seeing
a man in his gym jams and I'm like we're
not there yet I wi that was like What
episode two like episode three and I'm
just like that was episode two dude got
to episode two I'm and this is that's
what Mari I'm so with you to me no
disrespect I just feel she was out after
that I feel besides the show Runners
Pablo got a little too much power about
what he want to do with this situation
and my thing is look look you can take
it off all I'm just saying make the
situations earned that's all make it
make make those moment get paid by this
no I get that they not pushing your
character that's but do Vader said
different darph Vader said different
took his face off too we found out he
wasn't black oh my God oh my for a long
time for a long time I said you gonna
see James Jones
J off the they took the mask off I'm a
child in the movie I said oh my
God I said Darth Vader ain't black he a
living up to the Darth point I said I
thought Luke was lightskinn yo Mari fell
out the
G
walk
[Music]
around he comes out people ask him would
you feel about Star Wars man he ain't
black I know James Jones voice and then
when the mask came off I said
oh I've been
bamboozled so so please please I've been
it hurt early long time you already
ripped the band off so I'm happy I'm
happy y'all get
this we going move on it happened to me
your turn your turn tra traumatizes
trauma yeah he trying to tra hurt people
hurt
people and that is a wrap on that one
misery loves misery loves company we're
going to move on with me let's get to
the final one y'all we at we at we at
the end we at the end quick one too
super chats first get them all at once
oh you want to do Super Chat end yeah
let's just all on Jesse Derby $2 Super
Chat I'm assuming he's talking about um
about uh uh whatam call about jdubb
don't play games on PlayStation he plays
PornHub oh wow wow whatever you do your
personal time brother that's that's your
businesss that's your business you do
you then we have Lee Fitness once again
$5 Super Chat when Mari said Fifth
Element I was thinking there's people
walking around the show looking like
Ruby Ro shout out shout out to Chris
Tucker his most famous role most famous
role there we got hary chani $10 Super
Chat this whole having to take the mask
off uh to show a motion for Master Chief
is bunk Iron Man did it so it can be
done but further these are super
soldiers conditioned to not have emotion
it just cracks I'm makes sense and we
have midnight Druid $5 Super Chat tell
them to go ask Netflix how their
viewership went when they start when
they stayed ignoring The Witcher
Lord a lot of people didn't like the uh
The Witcher y finish the right we back
for the second time relax I actually
didn't watch the second season no I'm
talking about Halo we done now we back
back that was Cav's kind of I think part
of the reason why he left was that yeah
they were going
to situation was a that had everything
to do with Superman super he thought he
go back for Superman even before the
Superman thing they were arguing about
the direction that they were taking the
show yeah he got roped in by he probably
still would have stayed there but there
was a lot of friction between them it I
was one of those people where I'm like
Yeah The Witcher yeah I played the game
book I know books yeah read for real
this story yep I'm with you what you got
JD Gaber $20 Super Chat have the Halo
show Runners ever heard of environmental
storytelling leave the MC's Master Cho
helmet on use dramatic music the timber
of the voice how the other characters
react narrow to wide scene changes to
direct the emotion of Chief I got a I
got a thing for you every time he takes
his helmet off close your eyes and say
his helmet is
on messy continue There we have con
artistic $5 Super Chat in all
seriousness Miss Takahashi works with
ilp's chemistry at the very least once a
month we making contract demands told
you this woman has a life she has a
career 5 hours they like she got to be
here once a
month damn y'all extra extra don't need
to up that patronage if we can yeah how
about
that she come from 10 million you need
to share this
out let me see that we have Jason
Hendrick $5 CH during the random love
seeing she oh yeah we got I broke
protocol for that one that was too fun
we just Spartan $5 Super Chat oh my god
wow we saw cheeks we saw Master Chief's
head now we need to see the other head
no oh time on you time it's a it's
Sunday it's the Lord's day you out here
like this that's the Paramount plus plus
plus the commercial that's param after
that's param after do that's a that's a
different type of M that's a
different the sad part of is some was
prly done
a let's move on let's move on we going
left we going left master master meat
let's go moving on man
he threw Mas in front of it too which
was worse continue Alo has never made me
cry ever but I get why Master Chief
needs his mask on as if uh as if a fan
in video games he does not need a mask
on on a show okay it's true we got you
thank you Spartan 661 $5 Super Chat get
Spartan never takes their armor off
unless they are off duty Spartans are
always on duty he's not on duty when
he's on a Leisure Planet doing your
things he had his cheeks out he's having
he's relaxing Soldier relax that's only
on Halo reach
around oh she's lit you know we have
somebody that comes we literally have a
patron called Halo
Reach that's wow that was that was
awesome yeah he makes all his
inappropriate stuff towards me towards
add yeah
that's his only fans
contingent and we have Chris R $5 Super
Chat it's pretty clear that Showtime had
a Sci-Fi show in production that had
Halo slapped onto it somewhere in
production they
disrespectful we have black Ronin 357 $5
Super Chat uh The Last of Us was built
up like an episodic TV series and a
video game already Halo is not Halo is a
flat shooter with some story spots once
in a
while so you're saying they should have
never made a show about it that's say we
got JD gamer again $5 Super Chat panel
question does the Halo TV series make
you want to go play the game because the
games made us want to watch the TV
series in my opinion if not it failed oh
that's a good question it didn't make me
want to play the game fan already I I
guess you want very good question the
only way I would want to go play the
game is if I want an authentic Halo
experience yeah I guess you ask a non-h
Halo person person who doesn't know
somebody who never played the game I
will say cyber Punk uh Edge Runner is a
fantastic example of like oh I wasn't
playing cyber Punk but now kind of maybe
I'll play it now after I watch that
definitely was a great show big facts
and we have Sanchez MTZ gaming $2 Super
Chat all this is chicken propaganda Hal
show is good
salute yeah we have uh back from the
dead back from the dead
one he's gonna be at packs oh yes back
for the dead so there's no m cheeks
merch
coming no sir no sir they sell those
never mind let's go stop just stop just
stop move just Google we got we got
company we
got she fit right in
where yeah we keep acting like she's not
about to smoke yeah she's been about to
smoke since she came here I'm keeping it
levelheaded I'm just saying this light
for one time this is a very very clean
family friendly show for me right now
exactly this is light Mor light what
else we got then we have NC ghost of low
road $5 Super Chat the show didn't have
to be about Chief if he needed his mask
off I didn't care for the cheeks either
PlayStation guys do PornHub not us oh
Lord why you have to put that in there
why why they got to get slandered why
did PlayStation guys have to get SL
randomly continue then we have gamer by
choice $2 Super Chat lady mari's awesome
and great show Lord she is thank you
salute then we like then we have Doctor
Strange Love $2 Super Chat God I'd love
to see sa's Master cheeks that's oh boy
wow that that's that's different once
again thank you for your it's on a
different
website stay back back I say
back my God back to you off I ain't even
shave today man there we have parasite
parasite 82 green 10B Super Chat it's
okay King Sony got the new Wolverine
show dropping soon where they have
scrapped the blades and replace them
with nails from the street all painted
and
wow yeah it's their adaptation it's
their adapation no adaman oh Godless Ste
Wolverine that's
mess we got JD G again $2 Super Chat
Mari just make this your second home and
be on I sub that's they are shooting are
shooting their
shot I got I got to appreciate got to
respect I actually don't think this has
ever happened yeah I've never seen a GU
yeah this has never happened they like
make her the fifth ey Lord please oh
that's so nice y'all are so nice thank
you up uh yes sir we're up all right
final topic oh cuz we super long we can
get this through quick yeah all right uh
this king's topic a Suicide Squad kill
the Justice League a lot of talk in the
streets um shout out to King brought to
my attention the um developers had put
out a statement that they shrug off the
live service criticism it's still full
of the DNA that infuses the Batman
Arkham Series so I believe this is
Darius can't pronounce his last name s
San um the product director at
Rocksteady he spoke to play magazine he
said we knew we wanted to make a
four-player co-op game so he spent a lot
of times iterating on the characters so
this is defending the game's live
service format and um he said it wasn't
about making the game a particular genre
focus on creating a sense of flow
between all the gameplay systems he goes
on to say you want to build a community
with the game each player to feel like
they're part of the suicide squad and
yeah he just said that um I guess that
you know it's a little bit of a push
back now what is interesting the second
part is that um this is Kaku article as
far Kaku article in reference to the
previews because there was there was a
preview event that a lot of the media
went to which I guess gave like a
vertical slice of the game and that came
with mixed reception right some people
had issues with that and then there I
believe was a closed Alpha that a lot of
people got content creators got to play
and that was under NDA so we played
right so what has happened is rock
steady and W games they have lifted
partially lifted the NDA for the alpha
people because the the vibe is I guess
that more of the people who played the
alpha had more of a positive experience
so this is UN unprecedent in the sense
that the NDA is being lifted by that we
don't really see this it needed to be
right so King this is your time real
quick real quick um yes Mari the entire
time you been in the industry have you
ever seen that like someone lifts an NDA
like this like I've never seen
it oh
she sorry about that there you go you
good that was me pleading the
fifth you was under NBA at that moment
exactly um no I'm not a journalist so I
I just don't have a very good answer but
not that I've seen but I'm also not very
privy to it right I'm not like oh the
NDA is lifted oh my goodness got to
write an article about it yeah why you
got to be that thirsty though like
the J they go
o got move my shoulders like that I like
the oo part that was that killed me
don't doubt fair enough so King this is
your topic man where you want to go with
this bro well I I saw a lot of people
you know like dog piling on the game
yeah and you know majority of people
didn't play the game and they're saying
well I don't want a game with service I
don't want a game with service I don't
want to g a service y'all got Gotham
Knights y'all jump dog piled on that
that was the closest thing to the Arham
Knights uh Series yeah you had a little
frame rate hiccups there and stuff like
that and we know with those Rock Steady
games over time you get patches it'll
fix it up and you know the games look
good I thought I like Gotham Knights
myself I thought it was fun ROM I
thought uh each character played a
little bit different it wasn't the same
as uh the Arkham games still gota play
it's in Game Pass right now is it still
there yeah yeah I gota so you know the
flow is different it's not the same you
don't want the same when I played The
Suicide Squad I loved it I excuse me I
love each and every last character is
traversal the game is built around the
traversal aspect of each and every last
character I love
Boomerang um Harley Quinn plays more
like uh a Batman type of character
because her lineage is through Batman
and they they was very thoughtful with
their villains I want to play the story
aspect of it because they're supposed to
kill the Justice League how do you kill
the Justice League what is that part
about what what's going on with this
part so the game doesn't feel super
spongy when it comes to the uh shooting
the enemies this is the stuff that you
ask for you ask for it to have legs
sustainability is not in single player
games anymore right we know that so for
these companies to make money they have
to put these games of services in and
they have to do it thoughtfully the game
will live on if we support it but you
can't dog pile on it if you haven't had
a chance to play it yet
that's excuse me still got my cough no
you good the um the writers and stuff
that did get a chance to play or sort of
vertical slice went in on it and we
didn't have a chance to talk about it
because we was under NDA yeah and and
all the people that was under NDA the
majority of us like the game yeah that's
why that's why they lifted it to say
y'all can talk now so y'all can give
your side of it because y actually had
hands on with said game and I'm
anticipating the game no to to your
point just to be clear is that um again
sometimes you know obviously the Lords
we go to preview events and stuff like
that and saw you remember we we went to
certain ones and usually it's a it's a
vertical
slice that shout out to ref shout out to
um it's a vertical slice that usually
the developer wants you to see your
generally they're proud of right so in
this case whatever for whatever reason
people may have had issues with this
preview event that select press that
went to that but to King's Point it
seems like the alpha is completely
different more game in the game so to
speak and it seems based on you know the
people we've talked to that yo like a
lot of people do like it so it it's
polarizing right the graphically is
amazing the discussion about it but yeah
let's let's open this up let's lady Mari
first um you know what's your thought
process on this you know rock steady
lifting obviously in NDA for the people
who played the alpha and then just the
discourse I guess the question I have
for you specifically is the discourse
about it being live service because a
lot of people are like the hardcore
single player like s you know Arkam they
love those games and and people you know
may have some resistance that they're
going in a live service Direction and
worry about the quality of the game yeah
I mean I think with live Services we all
have a little bit of a of a a wound an
open wound where it's just like it's all
turning into this is it necessary um can
we keep things kind of uh U like holy
you know like can we just keep keep just
the sovereignty of what what the game is
and it always has been in its lineage um
but in other aspects it sometimes it
does work I can't really think of a game
right now that it has worked really well
right now when when it's changed all of
a sudden you know like I yeah um I feel
that but I I think I don't have major
thoughts on it because I just know I'm
not going to be playing it oh this not
for you this not for you I mean I think
part of it is this uh the the superhero
genre sort of like Funk Funk and fatigue
okay yeah and Funk and fatigue I haven't
watched watched um like a Marvel movie
in so long and I was you know up until
um did you stop uh at at endgame end
game yeah that was like Pinnacle that
was Peak it was end game I'm like yes 10
years we did it we over it's over and
then like the next phase dropped and I'm
like bro what
exactly invested but not this invested
like I was going to the movies like
movie theaters to watch I'm like I put
in a lot of work we're still going to
keep going so there's a little bit of
that so I feel like my biases are kind
of leaning towards there um my thought
goes is this is this leading towards
like the good Suicide Squad or the bad
Suicide Squad as far as the movies go
like is it going to be
fun are we going to have like it's fun
is there going to be humor is there be
like polka dot man and like rat catcher
and like those like wacky things or are
we leaning towards like like Arkham
humor where you know that like I I there
was a moment in time where I was I got
tired of just Batman just being like so
somber I was so serious and then I
played a little bit of Spider-Man I was
like I'm gonna go over here I'm this
this guy's having fun um but yeah I just
I don't have too much to say on it I
have to say the most Arkham that I've
played was maybe Arkham City on a 3D TV
do you remember that 3D TV jol yo that
was the fast have 3D capabilities that
yeah you put on glasses in the whole
game through we was fresh off of 1080p
we thought we was flying with 3 we
thought that was a Next Level yeah I
spent a lot of money on those glasses
remember that
TV like eight like eight pairs of
$300 back in the Box you clean the
glasses nice so that it's good for the
other guests yeah pretty sick and you
had to buy the battery I got them they
upstairs early adopters I remember
salute salute Mar but I don't have too
much to say I got kind of bored with the
games no fair enough that's where you at
that's where you at Lord addict your
thoughts on The Suicide Squad situation
lifting the NDA now uh I think that was
a mistake
I think King is the minority on here the
the majority of the people I talk to
that played they didn't like the
direction I didn't generally like it
because I felt like you know people play
differently but it wasn't a drastic
enough where I felt like I had like a
variety of gameplay style I feel like
everyone's like okay you got to jump
over here and I just I wasn't enjoying
what I play of it and you know people if
you like play Gotham ni you'll probably
like something like this but to me I
just I wasn't vibing with it like at all
and you know I played probably like an
hour and a half to two and I I played at
like the beginning of the alpha and I
never went back to it like that was
enough for me like and but but one thing
I will say is like it's a shame I didn't
like the gamepl because the story seems
to be there in like huge ways uh you
know I don't feel like they people like
well how they going to have the suicide
squad kill the Justice League uh doesn't
feel like they're nerfing
them it's the story The Narrative fol on
the game it Top Notch it Felts really
good as a narrative wise and that might
be something to get me to play it but
like the game play man is just I wasn't
vibing with that Gameplay at all okay no
fair enough fair enough sa I'm very
curious you are Lord Arkham you are the
single player is this the the the
ruination of your beloved people you
love rock steady bro like you go on the
F to where you at with this man I this
is going to be a game time decision to
me it really
is game time what is that is that wait
for the game pass bag what is that it's
going to be no it's going to be like I
may the foral may get me D one and I
just may cuz you know they they they've
also reiterated like hey this is the
most story we put in any one of these
games this no from a narrative it's
there man really that's big for addict
to PR like you you could ask King I'm
sure he could alliterate like there's
this part with Batman like that was
really good
so going back to the the preview event
apparently from what I heard and the
Travis was talking about this a little
bit this morning he didn't play the
preview event but he heard from other
people it's like what it was was it was
too controlled and on top of that there
were a lot of technical issues in terms
of just the stuff functioning in the
preview of it right and then instead of
like unlike the alpha they where they
just let you play it was a very
controlled environment and they wanted
to to say they they were like oh okay
we'll play with this character for 20
minutes jump to another character jump
to another character jump to this
scenario instead of just fluidly letting
you see how the game sort of opens up
yeah and so people were just not happy
with that and so kind of the The Taste
they got in their mouth from from that
was like oh I I don't like the way this
feels I don't like the way this plays
and it was in part due to that stuff
right ultimately if you don't like the
way the game plays or it feels or or the
life service aspects don't appeal to you
it's not going to appeal to you in the
long run so for me like I said it's game
time decision because the story stuff
has me intrigued uh same way that Gotham
knights was I knew what Gotham knights
was going in but the quarter all stuff
really had me Intrigue while I got to
see this see it yeah yeah and ultimately
I fell off and because initially the PC
version had some issues the technical
issues was rough but now now that's all
patched up I I'll go back to it
eventually just to see that story me too
um but my thing is really I kind of feel
like you they need to start getting away
from live service with these big IP with
known characters I think the live
service when you talk about the
longevity that you expect out of it
that's why it works with a game like a
fortnite or or or or or the you know a
pubg or even a Call of Duty where it's
like these characters they're known
quantities whatever but they aren't
these big IP that you sort of expect you
know to to to play a certain way perform
a certain way have certain personality
characteristics whatever you whatever
you know of this these characters right
either from the comics or from the
movies like whatever the case may be
there's kind of a predetermined thing in
most people's minds of what these
characters should be saying and doing
playing like weapons that they have
things of that nature so to try to put
those characters in this setting where
how game evolves is so important and
constantly giving you new stuff and
trying to figure out how to sort of
readdress these characters on a constant
basis I just think it's kind of weird I
think the name stuff feels more like a
cash grab and then you hope that the
game play is is strong enough that you
keep people in but I I just I was never
a fan of the idea of putting these big
characters in this type of game like you
know with with Avengers the best part of
Avers Avers fear yeah yeah the with with
Avengers the you know the the story
stuff was cool but it wasn't as cool as
it could have been because it was in
that engine that still had to adhere to
sort of that you know the the service
model and I thought it was weird like I
remember like getting like costumes like
part of the a big appeal of these games
is like going back into the comic LW or
whatever and getting these classic
costumes and stuff unlocking that stuff
and I remember in Avengers you unlocked
them but they had they had stat boosts
attached to them right but the thing is
the stat boost would act like under
arour in a way like you wouldn't see the
changes physically in the character I
was like what is this why would I why
would I care about this then but I can't
see it on the character in the game play
so I I don't know what what their plan
is in terms of that sort of stuff with
this game but to me it's it's how they
incorporate the entire Laura of Suicide
Squad into this and make it feel like it
it is really a love letter to Suicide
Squad right um the gameplay stuff again
from what I saw it seems different right
which is good I don't I don't want you
know if you go in there and start
countering dudes like Batman or whatever
yeah I would be like hey wait a minute
10 years and this is what you giv me you
can't win whatever what you do what
whatever you do with rockstead it needed
to be different
I would have wish they would have just
taken this team given us a team of four
made it into a co-op sort of brawler
slash shooter and forget about the
service model but whatever that's what
it is part of me is like I just wanted
like a variety of gameplay and I just
felt like it wasn't that like it wasn't
that it was just shooty shooty right and
mostly you know and again some people
love that some people don't um I would
have loved to have seen more variety
again I haven't played it yet so I I
will decide day one I I kind of think
the fomo will get to me and I'll get it
and then the steam version will be
garbage and I have to wait six months
play yeah like I'll jump in quick you
guys you know pretty much nail a lot of
my thought process with it I'm obviously
on a different I actually am the live
service guy but I understand you know
the the Legacy with rock steady and how
people really love those tight
controlled story single player without
any live service elements and I get that
and I get that and it's going to be push
back um I think what I I have no dog in
the fight because I have not played it
and then you know so I I respect when I
hear like addict or people that I talk
about it and it is mixed some people
were saying like yo the story is great
um you know but I don't like the way
they're hindering the live service
aspect then there's people that's like
yo Cog I love this game I don't know
what people are talking about right so I
think part of it may be the the the the
closed alha people may got more gam
playay under their belt instead of that
controlled environment maybe maybe they
just didn't do them maybe they did
themselves a disservice with the preview
event you know and obviously like what
you said that Travis said he had uh
technical issues whatever um shout out
to risk for the biscuit who's in the
chat he said he played the alpha and he
didn't like the alpha so it's polarized
it's one of those things but I I do
think it's interesting that they're
lifting the NBA because to me that
indicates yo the feedback we got
internally is Good from people we need
more people to know about this y y ain't
going to be trash at all game like I'm
getting
to me that's like ohing to contr the our
G not bad y'all and the developers
speaking out so it is I've never seen
that it's
weird IGN was getting Flack for their
title and I kind of agree like they they
said we played Suicide Squad and we
didn't like it in the title that that
feels very click baity because in the
past you just we played Suicide Squad
this is what we thought about it and
then you have to read the article to
find out they didn't like it it was like
it was a very like you're already I saw
homie think I did I think homie
Dustin D D's passionate when he don't
like something though oh when he doesn't
like something he Dustin is well aware
what SEO does are you implying as SEO
Dustin has been known to like messiness
so I apprciate that shout out to death
legary podcast a lock to the crew look
you know it's going to be one of things
got to see how it is wi it get shout out
to three bit in the chat see you bro um
yeah I I don't know I don't know what to
think you know I will say this to the
people who are against the live service
Avengers did leave a a stank in the room
that was just done poorly yeah so I I
understand and it is trust me completely
two different beasts I get it and I get
it and I'm one of the weird ones that
after you know all the content came out
for Avengers and I just played it for
what it is I love I love the Black
Panther story that black pan stuff you
got yeah black pan then they came in
Game Pass I was like okay you know what
say I can now rock out more you know I
bought I bought it for like three bucks
on like yeah yeah that price went down
that price went down so look we'll see
what happens but yeah interesting move
to remove the uh NDA but that's all I
got you want to
get get yeah let's let's respect that
time are you kidding I had a great time
that's a wonderful way to spend a Sunday
salute to
ladyi the legendary in the realm smash
ogs
so
Netflix she does it all y'all
choreography fight films what you want
what you want she do that she do that
she do all that and she's a gamer and
she's passionate you know we love being
atdi love the energy obviously when we
invited on oxog with you guys and and so
much fun and and it resonates and very
infectious personality love what you're
doing in the space where can the find
people find you what you got going on
lady Mar oh I have nothing going on but
it's
nothing and everything
right um but if you would like to follow
I'm Atomic Mari um across everywhere I
ask you the atomic part of mar what was
what's the significance were we trying
to go with that or that's a little no I
wish it was a cool story I I so wish it
was but you know my the first video went
live on smos pit weekly and my boyfriend
at the time husband now he's like no you
think you should have like social media
and I was like oh God know
probably and so um we were supposed to
drive out to Bishop to go rock climbing
where there's zero service so right
before we left I I hit upload and
everything was fine it was uploaded and
then I started a Twitter um and I was
like okay maybe I could go Mari KO like
knockout because my full name is Maro
and I was like no it doesn't work really
well F government fire I know kind of
cool Japan in the building Japan was
definitely in the building on that um
but I was like oh you know if it starts
with an a it's probably going to be
better with like um searching you know
this is algorithmic choices I love this
continue Sovereign
thoughts you know trying to be technical
we're talking 200 like maybe 10 or 11 at
this point I don't know what Twitter is
um and so uh Atomic I I thought it
sounded sciency I thought it sounded you
know like oh we're all made out of Adam
so you know it's it's like we're we're
all
connected and then years down the line
somebody in marketing who who's worked
with me she's like the atomic thing did
you ever think of like like the bomb
and oh my she the bomb y'all the bomb
that's it she she the
explosion yeah so that ruined me she's
like yeah I had to explain to everyone
that it was like familyfriendly
like marketing friendly I was like it
never occurred to me that me a Japanese
person name Atomic would have that
connection yes oh I didn't even think
about that you took me to do you think
do you think you could like reach out to
someone and get that change or like do
you not care that's a brand
now know who to call yeah we all we all
we all in
now
it is what it is it is what it is I
didn't even think about that I'm in 2
deep man I'm way too in deep definitely
3 now but salute to you and again a
pleasure thank you so much for rocking
out with us in the realm Lord adct want
to get an outro to Lady Mar before she
had yeah I definitely appreciate you
coming on uh I actually came across you
at smos games like 2011 something like
that remember how long ago it was
because I think when I first started
watching that you wasn't initially part
of that group I think you came neither
you were in the background a little bit
more and then you started doing that
more more often I wasn't living in La
yet a lot of the programming was done in
LA and so that's why but I I I launched
with them I just want I just had my own
show because then I could do it from my
house but yeah that's that's how it went
yes so I definitely uh appreciate you
coming on uh you know especially laser
core coming on a couple years ago
because you know that kind of domino
effect into you coming on mhm Get
Wrecked son that's my
man he bully his bully his kids if
that's my
man I'm glad he checked his email I'm
gonna just send him a text out of the
blue saying good job you you checked
your
email talking about Lord sa Lady Lady
Ming
outro I just love the fact that you're
jack of all trades and apparently master
of all and that that is awesome again
when I went to your your you know your
website like it says all the stuff that
you've done it doesn't give details
about what you've done who you but it
says I've worked in Nintendo say with
all these other companies and it's like
you've done either commercials or
something for them and that that is
really amazing to me that you can sort
of balance all of those sort of plates
and and still facts come out here and
have fun and and still like you were
talking earlier still keep the passion
for the gaming separate from some of
that and like certain games are like
sacred you have extra points in my book
for loving Red Dead to oh yeah knew that
was God you don't know the slander that
I suffer on the show I don't know what
I've been through what I've seen need
some back up I'm right here that's right
that's right thank you so much but
thanks for coming I I really appreciate
this was a great time today thank you so
much thank you appreciate it lady b Lord
King oh man um I did not really know
what to expect right to be honest with
you today and it is to some
clarification they never know who's
coming on until they're there yeah yeah
so we get like the text the night before
a couple of days oh yeah by the way yeah
right like surpris this is happening so
so I'm I'm doing my research and I mean
doing research on a person never gives
you the actual fail of the person
because we talk about story and history
and video game law and stuff like that
and seeing that you're a person that
takes control of her Destiny and and
like owns it M right you didn't know
exactly where it was going but you know
where you didn't want to go per like you
didn't want that dictated to you and
that's and for anybody that's watching
uh a traditional Japanese the reason why
I asked for a traditional Japanese
household there's expectations put on
the children especially the daughters
right um and and for you to blaze your
own path shows your character is very
very strong and your father saw that uh
boldness in your character and supported
you and gave you your first teleprompter
that stuff like that that stuff melts my
heart because I have daughters and I
want to be able to support them the same
way that he supported you and you know
your mother built a studio by hand all
the way up and I mean it takes it takes
a lot so you're doing what you're
supposed to do you're we
exactly kid honestly I appreciate it
great you're great she's awesome she's
awesome thank you I I wouldn't be able
to do what I'm doing without being able
to ride on the cails of so so many
people who have given you know thrown me
a bone and like this industry has all of
its really really um asinine terrible
bad parts yes the headlines will will
make you think that you should uh tuck
tail and run from the gaming industry
but my journey has
absolutely um flown in the face of that
because of one wonderful people like you
all and and it I I sincerely believe
that there is a place for all of us in
this industry you just got to find the
really really lovely pockets and um the
pockets that'll keep you safe and and
keep you going and I'm so so lucky to be
in this industry at all um and I and I'm
so grateful thank you guys so much
you're welcome again the legendary lady
Mori tremendous story again we're going
to be following you seeing your journey
and uh again really appreciated your
story very heartfelt blazing your own
path and to see your success is really a
blessing so do what you do enjoy your
Sunday let me get these last few super
chats that pertaining to oh pertaining
to her okay yeah okay sir X-Man $2 Super
Chat she better copyright that Halo
Reach Around powermount
PL I'm now a
producer then we have let me see hold
on Mari thank you for entertaining this
is Spartan 661 $5 Super Chat Mari thank
you for entertaining the realm of ILP
this show is our Sunday event and we
look forward to each Sunday thank you
for being here you are amazing
salute and then we have sir X-Men once
again $2 Super Chat all Hil Lord Atomic
bom and on that note we going to let her
go cuz you're being messy sir you're
being messy you know what you're doing
thank you so much Chad thank you for
being
lovely pleasure I will do the uh what
you call eye of the pole let me get up
out of here yeah we got a few
extra yeah there's a couple couple just
want to make sure she heard yeah
absolutely the wasn't potato her yeah
salute we have Doctor Strange Love $
five Super Chat Suicide Squad is hot
live service garbage that needs to Beck
click clacked like a rabbit animal this
game is do click clack you putting it to
sleep damn when tell them how you feel
play you'll realize and you'll be like
there's a lot of crow tastes delicious
then we have a be member for 28 months
Lord bronze Lords keep killing it love
y'all please speak on the bogus Xbox tax
article in IGN put out saying that
finally Xbox got
games they didn't see PlayStation last
year oh man yeah that's is a bit
hyperbolic I would say yeah your seven
time losers oh damn there we go
brisket for the biscuit with the 8
Australia in the house it's the homie
categorically disagree I guess he's
disagreeing with somebody Suicide Squad
yeah you know I know I just I wonder who
he was disagreeing guess King I guess no
he was disagreeing with the fact the um
the people who said that they liked the
alpha okay yeah categorically disagree I
have played it and it ain't it if you
like Gotham Knights then you may like it
if not avoid this rockstead
down oh
damn and I like aumn night so therefore
boom I like it shout to co co e Co East
with in the building just got home shout
out to the co co see you then we have
Justin buam $5 Super Chat I find suici
side Squad is a must play for Kevin
Conroy's last performance oh yeah that's
right forgot about that that's right if
you're about to develop an artist and
all that other my god oh my god king of
super messy that's super messy Contin
you then we have sir duck M for 42
months Lord bronze Suicide Squad is
going to kill WB at this R Great show
love this community y'all keep me
laughing out they dead
already uh then we got put the crust in
the chat for gamer by choice gifting one
IOP membership man bless bless a nobody
going to force you the game then
we it's your choice it's my choice my
choice there we have Donal taku $5 Super
Chat Suicide Squad feels like the Sunset
Overdrive sequel I've always wanted
movement and traversal will Paramount
and feel great boomerang is the best
yeah I heard I heard some overdrive
Vibes I heard Crackdown Vibes polar
people I'm telling you this is a
polariz this is a dope game and
Boomerang is the best to me salute then
we got parasite uh 82 green 5 pound
Super Chat LS need to use that Yakuza
money on snapping up Mari she straight
spitting bars stop pocket watching all
Yakuza money stop pocket watching that
don't worry about how much
that I can watch it bro hey so ju with
us if only you knew how long me and Co
stayed up making that sh making that Jo
exactly exactly just worry about this
funding is well funded yes send send us
over ju's bag though get Jui over here
on the show yeah
hit drei tell him he need to be in the
real continue drei
drei and we got black Ronin 357 $2 Super
Chat have a great weekend go watch solo
leveling go watch solo Oh I actually
want to watch that I need to get on that
know no go watch the book of Clarence
okay well solo leveling is like this
brand new anime that people are saying
is gonna be like the next big big
anime yeah go see black Jesus go see
book of Clarance the book of Clarance
yeah I know yeah yo it's dope you can
definitely do both in this world
unfortunately have not still not watched
the iron claw yeah we'll
see all right that's it we're caught up
oh we caught up let's get out of here RP
pole with the developing direct recently
announced which game do you think has
the biggest impact in
2024 a Indiana Jones machine games y'all
B AOW and obsidian see that hellblade
too that soft can't wait for my Ninja
Theory D I don't care y'all better stop
fronting on Call of Duty and the ABK
acquisition the choice will go up go
rock the poll when it goes up again
shout out to Lady M shout out to
everybody in the realm dope episode more
fun things plan another good show next
week anything else I'm gonna send you
guys over to to ASA shout out the game
On Da send you guys over there go there
tell you IOP raid man tell IOP raid no
doubt one more promo we just R we going
to send them over just do the promo
again promo last time you already know
salute again Sega salute to the whole
team and you already know infinite
wealth coming soon hit that link hit
that link it's in the description go
check it out go merch in
stor you can't save Kong go all at T
spring all that and again great show
y'all if you know must heart oh man
anyway great show we G to leave y'all
with some promo
peace J welcome to beautiful Hawaii as
we a the latest installment in the
yakaza series like a dragon infinite
wealth with all man our under dog hero
ichan kazaka the legendary hero of
Yokohama teaming up with everyone's
favorite the legendary dragon kiru and
all the favorites that's coming back we
got The Lovable homie cop Dai you know
what I'm saying we got Jun Gian SM
assassin and our hostess with the
mostest AO n it's so many people coming
back as well as a new casting characters
and we're going to see what's going on
as we play some of the best inter turn
base combat goodness mini games
heartfelt story and of course you know
when it gets sticky you got to call the
pound mates
man if it get crazy you goonna hit the
submits them kab submits it's gonna get
crazy we got here and we're ready to see
what is going on in this latest epic
story and here we go January 26 2024
it's coming out Playstation Xbox Windows
steam pre-order now get the heroes
booster pack special job set before it's
too late for more information visit
infinite wealth. sega.com and look I
can't stay too long y I got to get over
to dundu Island um I don't know if you
heard cuz I'm building out my little
tourist hotspot my personal situation
going on over there so I'mma catch y'all
later
peace
ah Welcome To Paradise
[Music]
hello all right I can show you around
now but there's a few things you need to
learn before we have a good time it's
y you can have a little fun with some
friends and even pick up a new
skill
whatever you do be
careful even Paradise can have his
secrets you trying to tell me there a
Yakuza in Hawaii not exactly something
you'd find in a guide book is it keep
your friends close and your enemies
closer names Dwight nice to meet you
take
cover
a